how about uh there we go thank you uh
good morning and welcome to the uh first
session of Criminal Justice for the year
representative Newman good morning how
are you
all right
um for the members who are new here uh
my name is representative Roy I'll be
the chair this year
um we're going to start off the year
with the orientation session we're going
to hear from several state agencies and
um several lobbyists they're going to
kind of fill us in on what they do
because we're going to see them a lot in
this committee so I encourage you all to
take in as much as you can
make notes for yourself if you have
questions for them
ask them a question if you have a lot of
questions for them I encourage you to
talk to them after we should be
completing today sometime around noon
say anyone have any questions before we
start
okay
well we'll just hold on for a second
foreign
thank you Mr chairman my name is Richard
head I'm the government Affairs
coordinator for the judicial branch I'm
going to be joined and they're on their
way up the stairs I think by judge Spath
um Concord circuit court judge and Terry
McCafferty the Concord Circuit Court
Clerk of Court
and I just wanted to talk in terms of of
opening comments and I appreciate the
opportunity to talk with you about sort
of the court system you're going to be
seeing a lot of me throughout the course
of the session
um and and in my role as as a government
Affairs coordinator I I sort of manage
all of the bills that have an impact on
the judicial branch and a lot of that
you'll hear me talk about is fiscal
impact because the bills are going to
have impacts on the resources of the
court system
affect the way in which we process cases
or the
um the timing of cases where there are a
number of bills that are in the session
that would require us to hear cases
within a certain period of time so you
hear you'll hear me say I don't have a
policy the court doesn't have a policy
position on the bill but I will talk
about how it impacts our procedures and
our processes I am here I'm hope I I
hope as a as a resource if at any time
anyone has questions always feel free to
reach out to me uh
you can call me by on my cell phone you
can email me and I try to be very
responsive if for whatever reason I
don't don't hesitate just to keep
calling me and I apologize if I'm if I'm
delayed
I did want to just talk generally about
what our court system looks like judge
math and clerk McCafferty will fill in
some of the details but just to sort of
talk through what is our system we have
two trial court systems we have the
superior court and the circuit court
within our Circuit Court we have three
divisions that themselves used to be
courts they were all merged in 2012 into
a circuit court system so Family
Division probate Division and District
division are all part of the circuit
court so so a circuit court judge hears
everything that is in circuit court so
they can hear probate cases they can
hear family cases and they'll hear
District cases district is really the
the division that you're interested in
that's a criminal and civil cases are
heard
and that's that's really where you know
the stuff that you were involved with is
interacting with the judicial branch
the Superior Court here's the felonies
the Circuit Court here's the
misdemeanors and violations beginning
January 1st last session the thing
called felonies first was repealed
felonies first
changed our processes back in 2015-ish
and had all of the felonies get heard uh
in in Superior Court I'm going to pause
briefly
and just introduce judge
and Terry McCafferty clerk of the court
in in terms of of our presentation as
they settle in I'm just going to give
some background and really what they're
going to try to do is is put a little
sort of life in terms of what a criminal
case is when it comes before the system
uh when it gets into the court system
and sort of how does it get managed
throughout the process
and and so in in Circuit Court as I said
you know a circuit court judge hears
cases from all divisions and sometimes
they're hearing them all in the same
morning session you know whatever is
coming through is going to be heard by
that by that court or by that judge
and in general when a layout and then
I'll be corrected in about 10 minutes or
10 seconds in terms of what I say uh and
and that's fine because they actually
know what they're talking about
if you look very generally at what a
circuit court
system is going through on a on a week
and I have like this week's docket is
here it's 49 Pages uh for the Concord
Circuit Court
on Mondays in the morning that's when
you get arraignments
um so that's you know I'll give rough
number 65 arraignments are coming
through that's until 11 o'clock 11
o'clock that shifts to video so those
are the you know uh 8 30 to 11 is live
11 o'clock is going to be video
arraignments and we don't know how many
video arraignments are going to be lined
up in that particular morning video is
set up with the with the jails and is is
frequently Limited in terms of time
because they're going from one Court to
the next so we may have an hour uh with
with the jail and then they're moving on
um
but we don't have a good sense of how
many video arraignments necessarily are
going to happen and then Monday
afternoon criminal trials and the
Overflow from the morning that couldn't
necessarily that could not necessarily
get reached Tuesday Morning criminal uh
proceedings trial management comp uh
trial management hearings competency
suppression pre-trial sort of criminal
stuff 11 o'clock go back to videos and
then in the afternoon criminal trials
um Wednesday mornings abuse and neglect
full hearings these are
much more complex or incredibly complex
hearings they take time and they require
sort of lengthy orders when they're
ultimately you know a judge has to
ultimately write something down
afternoon juvenile cases juvenile has
its own sort of procedural issues in
terms of them having confidentiality
issues the scheduling of them has to be
staggered because you can't have
everybody in the courtroom at the same
time so there are some very complex sort
of scheduling and just management issues
associated with that
frequently these are cases that involve
an arrest where police have a very
limited period of time they can hold the
juveniles they happen very quickly they
can be held for four hours and have to
get in front of a judge
um
so you have some very complex both types
of cases and scheduling and management
of cases due to the nature of of those
Thursday tends to be civil and then
Friday are state criminal cases State
Police
um and and stuff that's that's generated
out of the state system every day you
have walk-ins you have the the cases
that are not scheduled
stalking domestic violence uh ex parte
dcyf guardianships juvenile arrest again
where they have to be where police has
the the juvenile has to be before a
judge within a limited period of time
um and then you know all of these are
being held by the same or being heard by
the same judge so this isn't you know
one judge for criminal one judge for
juvenile you know they hear all types of
cases within the Circuit Court we have
about I may be off by one or two we have
42 full-time judges
and then we have on the superior court
side where the felonies are being heard
civil cases and and stuff that's that's
on the Civil side we have 21 judges
there
in terms of rough numbers in the Circuit
Court total number of cases that are
being filed for those 42 judges is about
a hundred and five hundred and ten
thousand of those criminal cases we're
talking about 51
000 to 55 uh 65 000 depending on the
year so that's just the criminal docket
is about 50 to 65 000 in the superior
court side where we have about 21 judges
uh it's nine to ten thousand cases uh
criminal cases that are being heard
there
um civil cases we're talking in the in
the Circuit Court about 5000
um and then sort of I could run through
the numbers but there's just a lot of
cases and a lot of volume so essentially
every day they are people are in front
of them they're moving those cases and
then people are showing up again and
they're moving those cases and then in
between they have to write the orders
they have to research they have to do
the other stuff but I did think and and
so I turn it over and ask uh judge math
and clerk McCafferty just introduce
themselves give a little background but
just you know what happens in a criminal
case in the court system and how does it
what are the sort of steps that a
criminal case takes once it shows up in
the in the court system so if it's all
right with you two I'll just ask you to
introduce yourselves and and and just
start through the system or through this
good morning first I would like to
apologize for our tardiness I do have
I've already had my morning docket at 8
15 and 9 15. I was able to sneak out if
you will because my 10 o'clock case was
continued so I do apologize for the
delay I have been a circuit court judge
for 11 years almost 12 years I have been
an attorney for 38 years I started my
career as a state public defender also
served as a federal public defender
served five years as the deputy Clerk of
Merrimack County Superior Court and then
the 11 years before I was appointed to
the bench I was at the Attorney
General's office so I am pleased that I
was able to have such a diverse
background
I have
recently taken senior status which means
I am technically retired but I sit one
day a week still in Concord my first six
years on the bench I truly did ride the
circuit and I sat all over the place and
in fact Salem was one of the places
where I got to know representative
Manion because he was a police
prosecutor back then and so it's nice to
see you in another setting uh and Terry
will speak to you about her background
and then we thought we would take you
through the life of a criminal case
my name is Terry McCaffrey I'm the clerk
of the Concord Circuit Court I've worked
for the court for 19 years I've been a
clerk for 13 and I've been in Concord
for eight years so as um
attorney had mentioned injured Scott
mentioned the circuit Court's very busy
as Clerks of Court were responsible for
the entire court which as you know
circuit court is family civil district
some probate I don't have to have a
probate but um you know this this just
uh a lot of cases as attorney had
mentioned um it's just a very busy Court
we you know we as clerks just kind of
oversee everything that's going on in
the court uh day to day and it's busy
constantly running we're very short
staffed in Concord right now I have
for full-time Port assistant three
positions open which is a step up from
quarter 62 is the entry level quarter
system three I currently have four
full-time positions open so all of that
work those four people do are now on the
backs of the other people uh that are
working there so it's it's kind of
stressful right now in Concord
so can you just explain what the cases
that you brought and sort of what so
what I brought was some criminal cases
if anybody wants to take a look at them
um as judge staff mentioned this would
you know outline the history of the case
there's two these are criminal cases
there are two different color folders
the the ones that are green are to grab
the Court's job's attention
um uh more quickly because they contain
criminal Bill protective orders which
are similar to uh domestic violence
restraining orders or civil restraining
orders
um so so we have to pay close attention
to them when they come down from court
to make sure that that criminal Bill
protective order hasn't been amended
that doesn't need to be faxed
um to the DB registry for entry or to be
removed from ncic so that's that's what
these cases are so um if you I'll pass
them around if you want to take a look
at them you'll see the criminal
complaint the way it comes in you'll see
the sentencing order you'll see any bail
conditions you'll see on this side
Financial affidavits for time to pay so
they're just um
that's the the green fold of the the
vanilla folders are just regular cases
DWI Criminal Trespass Class A or Class B
misdemeanor
so if anybody wants to take a look at
those
in the Circuit Court in the criminal
world we hear Class A misdemeanors which
means there's a potential for jail time
and those are the cases where if someone
qualifies they are entitled to a
court-appointed attorney Class B cases
are do not carry uh potential jail time
so people are not entitled to an
attorney there and then violations which
are generally like your motor vehicle
cases they can be the the speeding the
handheld violations of texting and those
kinds of things so how we first get a
criminal complaint which is the charging
document
and is
it comes in one of well it always comes
to the court first and it comes in
either because someone has been arrested
they were bailed by a bail commissioner
who gave them a court date for a later
date uh sometimes the police departments
will give a person a hand summons which
will tell them what date they're coming
that is usually for something like minor
the Third Way an arraignment starts is
if someone is arrested and held
overnight without bail or with bail they
are unable to make and at that point the
court would hear that case when Richard
was talking about video arraignments
those are for the people who were
arrested the night before so I'll hand
it over to Terry to talk about what they
do when the complaint comes in and then
when we get to that first arraignment
I'll talk to you about what we do as
judges at that point
so when the case first comes in whether
it is by just you know handing it over
the counter by the police department or
they mail it in or by uh email we do
allow them to email them to the court if
it's for the next day or that day
um the clerk's office enters it assigns
that a document number creates the
folder puts all the necessary paperwork
in here bail orders advisement of Rights
a few things like that if they're
detained we don't assign an attorney
um up front they'll ask for that on the
record and we'll schedule them for their
next event with an attorney
um
and they should have if they're detained
they should have a probable cause
affidavit if they're not detained then
they don't usually have that
there'll be a financial affidavit also
if they're detained and will assign
Council uh that day during the
um video uh bail hearing
so at arraignment people are not
entitled Attorneys at a rainbow
even an individual who has been held
overnight and is having that initial
arraignment uh what happens with those
cases is by Statute if someone is still
held at the arraignment then they are
get are appointed an attorney the
attorney can request for an immediate
bail hearing so it will get reviewed
very quickly but for the people that
walk in on their arraignment date there
are a couple of things that could happen
one is generally speaking the prosecutor
will speak to them first to see if they
want to work out a plea bargain at their
arraignment that does happen with some
frequency for some of the lower usually
for the lower type offenses uh if it's a
plea I take it that day and we we go
through the acknowledgment of Rights
form and the person's pleats that day I
if someone wants a trial or is asking
for a court appointed an attorney I I
will read the charges against them
review their bail and then if it's a
Class A misdemeanor and I've determined
they qualify for an attorney we then the
next thing that scheduled as a trial
management conference or a case status
hearing if it's a Class B misdemeanor or
a violation and the folks want a trial
the next the date they will be given
that day will be that whatever their
trial date will be so those are the
files that I just then hand over back to
the clerk
and we process it we assign Council if
it's a Class A
we sent it downstairs if they are
fleeing to pay their fine or get their
paperwork
fax paperwork to the jail if it's a if
it's a an arraignment all of our
arraignments are done by WebEx now
nobody travels to the court we have been
doing telephonic for our video for a
while but now everything is WebEx we do
we do a good a good amount of hearings
by WebEx particularly bail hearings that
the public defender has asked for which
rescheduled within 24 hours of course
they might be at another court so we do
all of those by WebEx and and uh the
public defender and state may appear by
WebEx as well
so then the clerk's office is is
determining based on the calendar what
the next court date will be and when
with that next court date if it's the
class A it will be the trial management
conference
uh ideally by that time the defendant
does have an attorney uh as I know
you're probably all aware there has been
a real backlog with finding attorneys to
take the cases so
at this point unfortunately it
frequently occurs that at the trial
management conference the individual
still has not received their court
appointed attorney at which point we
explain and apologize and we do have to
continue them but if the trial
management conference goes forward
a couple of things could happen again at
that point the case could plead out the
prosecutor and the defense attorney at
that point time may have come to an
agreement if that's the case I will take
the plea at that time uh if it still
looks like it's a trial then I get the
information we need and what the clerk's
office will need as far as the length of
the trial so we know where we can try
and fit it in how many witnesses they
both sides expect to call and if there's
any pre-trial motions is there going to
be a motion to suppress is there going
to be a motion to exclude some other
evidence and those are all discussed and
deadlines are given for when those
motions can be set when discovery which
is the police reports and all of the
evidence against the individual that all
has to be turned over to the defendant
or defense counsel and all of those kind
of anything that's sticky we try and
take care of at that time and then when
when I'm finished with those that
paperwork then the clerk's office gets
the file again yep and we send it out to
all the parties we give them a trial
date schedule would send out to the
parties
one of the things that I didn't mention
when we do the first arraignment there's
a lot of information a lot of paperwork
that has to go with packets that go to
the public defender's office they get a
copy of everything in the file as well
as hearing nurse everything in the file
as well as hearing loss is also scanned
to the jail so it's very paperwork heavy
processing wise for the for the clerk's
office
then when the notices go out for the
trial or also
neglected anywhere along this way there
can be motions to continue that are
filed maybe an attorney is in another
court maybe there's some other conflict
so the clerk's office is also processing
a lot more paperwork frequently in these
cases because it's
it's not uncommon for that first trial
management conference date or that first
trial date to not occur because of a
conflict not a court conflict but of the
parties a witness may not be available
sometimes those things come up as well
but if we get to the trial date
um
again at that point the defendant and
the pro the state may have worked out an
agreement and there may be a plea
instead of the trial if it's a trial and
they're ready to go and they shouldn't
be by that date we will have the trial
if we have the trial or The Plea again
the court makes a ruling generally
speaking the court is able to make a
ruling and if it's a guilty finding we
will do sentencing right then and there
occasionally I may take a case on under
advisement if I just
need time to think about it one of the
things I I have been involved in
training a lot of new judges and one of
the things I really impress upon them is
don't feel rushed give this person their
full day in court and there may be
something that you heard at the
beginning of the trial that at that
point you didn't understand how
important it was going to be when they
tied everything together and so I may
want to go back and look at my notes
it's rare but occasionally I might go on
a view in a district court case where
there's something about an intersection
and what occurred at the intersection or
at a restaurant and where this
altercation may have occurred and I've
always found it very helpful to do that
as well but if if the case is concluded
and the sentence is giving given
frequently that will include a fine and
again at that point the individual is
asked to return to the clerk's office
and then the clerks take over again
and we uh the majority of people don't
have the ability to pay that day of
court and ask for a time payment
um so they fill out a fine payment a
financial affidavit and then the clerk's
office simply asked them what they uh
what they can reasonably afford to pay
each month and then we give them a
payment notice and then we collect
payment usually because typically we
don't usually do 90 days full full you
know at the end we say okay so we'll do
30 30 Because by the time 90 days comes
they kind of forget about it you end up
with more defaults so we just kind of do
a routine a routine payment so again
that's more work for the clerk's office
they're calling in because they can call
in a pay it's either calling in over the
phone there's a lot of foot traffic
coming in to make all those payments so
the fine payment piece you think it's
closed because they you know they they
entered their plea or there was a
sentence but then that can take you know
on its own life as it continues I need
more time to pay so the payment pieces
is another uh uh pretty good workload
for the clerk's office and there's a
miss miscellaneous other types of
hearings that the court hears one of
them would certainly be a fine payment
hearing if a defendant has been given a
lot of time and still hasn't made any
effort they'll go before the judge and
we'll talk about what is going on uh
other cases there may be a motion to
impose a sentence an individual in a
class A misdemeanor case may have gotten
30 days at the house of correction
suspended for one year condition upon
good behavior which usually means they
have no other felony misdemeanor or
major motor vehicle violation offenses
if they commit those the state can file
a motion to impose the sentence and then
we would have a hearing on whether that
previously suspended sentence would be
imposed we have competency hearings if
anyone it can be the state that's
typically the defense or the judge
raises the issue of whether a defendant
is competent then then he or she is sent
for a competency evaluation and then we
have a hearing with the doctor and the
court determines whether the defendant
is come or not
extradition hearings when someone has
committed a crime in another state and
is found and there's a warrant out for
their arrest and they are found in New
Hampshire we then have a hearing to
determine whether that person will waive
extradition and willingly go back to the
state where they have the warrant or
whether they will challenge what's
called a Governor's warrant where they
can put the state through their Paces of
that this is the individual and this is
the person who should be returned to
non-compliance with bail conditions we
do in in Concord are fortunate enough to
have a pre-trial services division for
the county and so if someone has been
put out on bail and are violating some
of their conditions of bail maybe they
were supposed to get a drug abuse
evaluation or report every weekly to
pre-trial services and they haven't then
we would have a hearing on their
non-non-compliance and and what what
will happen then sometimes people's bail
is revoked sometimes tighter conditions
are are placed and again sometimes at
that point a person may plead guilty and
we take care of the case at that point
we do have a lot of motions to review
bail frequently they are in domestic
violence cases where an individual who
has a no contact order and the parties
do wish now to have contact and those by
law have to be heard pretty quickly
and the judges also handle search
warrants uh they just recently changed
the process the entire time that I was a
Jud I was sitting full time
Terry was smart enough and and I
appreciated very much she set two times
a day when police departments could come
in to have their warrants and frankly it
was 8 30 before I started my morning
docket and at 12 30 before I started my
12 45 docket uh and they would they
would come in person pre-coped and I
would review all the forms and determine
whether they would get a search warrant
or not uh now
there is now a streamlined a Statewide
streamlined way they do the search
warrants and so one judge is assigned
for a week at a time and handles all the
search warrants uh throughout the state
and then they're not given a docket
while they're doing that so they're not
trying to fit them in like I was trying
to do and other judges had to do prior
to this system
um and so for all of those different
motions the clerk's office again has
additional work it's very busy close-ups
and very busy public defender drops off
their mail about 2 30 in the afternoon
and it is just filled with requests for
to modify bail either
the majority of them are criminal Bill
protective orders at the protected party
wants to have contact
UM or they could be held on a cash bail
and they want to review the cash bail
they want to be released on a on a PR
bail so
um you know as Joseph mentioned lots of
motions to continue it's very
it's it may seem that the case goes to a
first arraignment then you know a trial
management conference in a trial but the
case must be pulled for some kind of
filing at least three or four times
before it gets from arraignment to that
trial date so it's it's very very busy
in the clerk's office and Terry reminded
me by talking about those when any of
those motions come in after it's been
processed the judge then needs to review
them and make a ruling so we have what
we call a signing desk which literally
when I get to it at the end of the day
can be like this High just with criminal
and there's all the other kind of cases
that you deal with but again normally
during the course of the day we don't
have time to review anything other than
our docket and emergencies that come in
I also neglected to talk about mental
health Court Concord is fortunate enough
to have a mental health court and
individuals who uh
come to mental health court are
sentenced to mental health court and
they usually have a suspended House of
Corrections time hanging over their head
in order to comply with mental health
court and it's one of my favorite things
I do to be honest with you these people
work so hard to be in compliance
generally a lot of them have a dual
diagnosis of a mental illness and and a
drug addiction so there's a lot there
they are helped to a lot of requirements
there's counseling you know they have to
work have to look for work they have to
attend all of their counseling they're
so motivated and it's a pleasure to do
but again because of our docket I do
that at 12 15 during lunch because we
just have to fit it in but it's I think
it's incredibly helpful we have lots of
graduates lots of people who graduate
and it's one of the nicest things that
we see
and um and I'm just going to interrupt
it you've been very generous with your
time um and I know you have a very busy
day so I don't want to fill up anymore I
think what I would suggest unless you
had any final comments is we would be
happy to take questions
um but we've we've taken up some of your
time and we appreciate the the
opportunity
and in the committee thanks you you're
on a Madam Clerk and Mr Richard hat for
coming in today
um I I would be interested in discussing
later the potential for setting up a a
field trip for the committee to be able
to come in and see a session of Criminal
Court
um if the members are interested um I
think that would be incredibly helpful
and I agree and I'd be happy to
coordinate that with you today anytime
thank you and I also just had a couple
of quick questions
um and maybe I could knock out some of
the committee has as well
um can you real quick tell us why
um why so many videos versus in person
the videos are generally the people who
have been arrested the night before so
they're being held at a house of
Corrections and instead of incurring the
cost of transporting them to the jail I
mean from the jail to the court uh
they're they're they we now hold them so
they're at the jail when they have the
hearings so those are the types that are
generally done that way occasionally
also on a competency hearing the doctor
may appear by WebEx as opposed to coming
to the courthouse and again that's based
on their availability okay many more
hearings held by WebEx uh during covet
obviously but but even still it's kind
of continued because some of the folks
that are incarcerated I think some of
the jails still have their own protocols
and if they go out then they've got a
quarantine going back in so that they
prefer it the the the folks incarcerated
really prefer to be by WebEx rather than
um
another question I have is
um you mentioned the the difficulty in
finding um attorneys to take cases can
you can you talk to that uh real quick
about like why is that difficulty and
what if anything the the legislature so
you know there's there's
primary issue is just volume within the
public defender's office and number of
public defenders I think others could
speak more specifically to to Staffing
the public defenders are are not funded
or managed through the court system but
you know you've you've heard I think
over the past year about the shortages
in in the public defender system and
then separately there are contract
attorneys that we we will fund or funded
through
um through judicial Council in order to
sort of make up some of that but again
it's a it's a limited pool of attorneys
who are available or willing to do that
so you have you know sort of no control
over the number of cases but a shortage
of attorneys and you know just the
similar to sort of the number of cases
that are heard before the court Jud are
attorneys can only manage so many cases
at a time and and they're tapped out so
it's it's really a resource issue in
terms of available public defenders and
then available contract attorneys who
would pick up any of the the difference
I know that in some other states I think
particularly one to our South they used
to at least have it so that as a member
a bar membership I think they had to
take so many Public Defender cases per
year a judge could just look at an
and some of it is is what is the ability
of the attorney
there are a lot of people who would
prefer not to see me showing up to to be
representing them in a criminal case
um and so the bar does have a public
service
objective but it is not tied
specifically to the criminal practice
okay all right that's something that I
find interesting I'd like to talk to you
about later that'd be great
um
one thing that this committee deals with
a lot when we we make criminal law is
fines and sometimes you'll see a
representative say you know fifty
thousand dollar fine
obviously that that's uh Beyond
unrealistic how often do you see
um people that are end up having to be
incarcerated because the fine was just
too high or or could you speak to a
little bit about the the fines back
was when I was a public defender it was
pretty common to be honest that a
defendant would serve out their fine at
that time it was fifty dollars a day
that would get credited towards a fine
now it is a hundred and fifty dollars a
day
but the court will not just send someone
to jail
for their fine it has to be an ability
to pay issue and to be honest
any case where someone isn't paying a
fine in my experience has been they
don't have the ability at that time so
we'll we'll try to stagger how much they
pay uh community service is also an
alternative to work off your your fine
what happens sometimes though was
someone may have been held pre-trial
before they made bail or until their
plea and we can if that's the case we
can credit them 150 a day for each day
that they were held free trial so you
see a fair amount of fines
taken care of that way as well okay
great and uh the last question I had
um and it's kind of related to the fines
was what is the court seeing as far as
the homelessness problem as far as being
able to to track a defendant to um know
where they are
um is that becoming an issue as far as
some ways again there are there is a
large number of homeless individuals who
do get charged with crimes a lot of
times the bail the notices get returned
if we even have an address for them a
lot of them don't have even an address
again in Concord there is a homelessness
Resource Center that allows defendants
to receive their mail at that address so
that has helped uh with with increasing
the number of people who do appear I
don't know if you have a different
observation I think it's a difficult
issue I think we've had
um you know we've had cases where they
file the motion to continue and we've
the judges had to deny the state's
motion to continue because the defendant
is homeless they won't be able to get
mail they won't know when the new
hearing date is
um or it it it's it's really a difficult
issue for the clerk's office
um
we just can't you know you'll you'll
have a person that will
um even if they're even if their mail
goes to the 238 North Main Street
address
um
that address is the person has to go
asking hey do I have any mail and so
sometimes after I think it's three
months or so the resource center will
send us back all the mail that people
didn't pick up so you know and homeless
is as you know is tied to mental health
issues and I think it's it's a real
challenge for the court system for sure
and do a lot of the homeless end up in
warrant is that
they could because sometimes a lot of
times if people don't appear on Crosby
or violation of offense and they're
homeless we wouldn't typically issue a
warrant but sometimes that's the only
way we can get find them as a PR warrant
and then they'll you know they get
picked up and then we try to get them a
new date but it's it's really hard okay
um
I can't see your name tag
I should know it within a week or so go
ahead
go ahead represent it thank you um so
I'm just curious I know from some
friends experience that the court system
got very
um got stalled and very backlogged as a
result of the start of the pandemic and
I'm wondering to what extent you've been
able to sort of clear that backlog to
get to sort of regular backlog as
opposed to extreme backlog
I think the backlog as far as covid has
uh cleared up I think what I'm doing now
is you'll see a backlog again in civil
cases and
um
concrete pre-trial conferences pre-trial
conferences our speeding ticket
low-level things like that that has Fine
amounts what they're called plea by
males so if you get a parking not a
parking ticket but a speeding ticket or
um uninspected vehicle those things that
have 62 dollar fine that kind of thing
on them we schedule those for pre-trial
conferences
um but I've had to pause those I haven't
scheduled any yet for this year because
I don't have the staff to process them
um I'm I'm going to be pausing the Civil
payment hearings you know small claims
where they've won judgment and someone's
problem motion for payments I have to
pause those because I don't have anyone
in the Civil Department I do not have a
civil Department right now
um so those are getting paused but
because of staffing issues and not
because of covid
thank you for taking my question
um I know that in the uh there that in
the last couple of years I've heard uh
numerous times in the committee that um
there's also a staffing situation uh
within the court system itself uh can
you talk a little bit about that is that
something that's that's gotten better
gotten worse
most businesses have increased their
salaries right you saw it everywhere
um you know companies went up to Fifteen
dollars eighteen dollars my son works
for Amazon he said I think their minimum
pay is twenty dollars an hour so I think
that's a big factor for the court system
to try to attract people
um we're starting our court Assistant
two position that starts it's about 15
an hour so there's a lot of you know
conversation around well that's what
they're paying at Dunkin Donuts that's
what they're paying at Walmart and we
try to have those conversations with
people but this is a different job this
is a career track you can have a good I
started as a course assistant too at ten
dollars an hour in 2003. so it's
possible to have a good career track but
it's sometimes hard to reach people in
that mindset because they're they're say
themselves I understand that but I need
to pay my rent
um people that started the court system
you know at that fifteen dollars an hour
unless you are have a roommate or in a
relationship it's really hard to make
that make it on your own on that kind of
salary so I think that that's why we're
seeing reduced staff in most sports and
they're really two aspects to the staff
shortage we have seen and it does exist
throughout the system so uh within the
clerk's offices all of them are short we
often will put out a notice of a
position opening and there are no
applications
and in that's common for the
applications we see are simply you know
for that position not qualified and we
do try with a lower level clerk
positions to say you know this is an
opportunity it's a it's a way of getting
into the court system and you have the
opportunity to advance but salaries are
are difficult and then this the other
aspect of the shortfall is we've just
completed a weighted case study that
um for the first time since 2005 that
talks about really for the cases and the
number of case as we have what should be
the full Staffing and what should be the
full number of judges and even if we're
fully staffed we're short
so so you know we have two aspects of it
one is to get to the fully staffed
aspect of it and then the second is just
how do we get enough staff that how do
we get
the the sort of the definition of fully
staffed moved so that we can actually
manage the caseload and both of those
are just sort of compounding on each
other now I think you'll see it in the
chief justices budget presentation where
both of the the judicial resources and
the Staffing Resources we're seeking to
address and you'll see some of that in
the budget
have have you um have you tried
recruiting at the State House here
because I think fifteen dollars an hour
is a lot more than we make so you might
find some takers we'll put some notices
in the elevator it wouldn't be a bad
idea
um we could talk to you all day it's
incredibly fascinating
um oh one more question
I'm sorry I didn't mean to cut you off
Concord District Court does not but
um as I said um amazing stuff and I
would love to talk to you all day I will
get with attorney head after and see if
we can't arrange a field trip to come
visit you in your in your environment um
I think there's a lot to learn there and
uh thank you your honor thank you madam
Clerk and thank you attorney head for
taking the time to come see us today
up next we have the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence
and no worries about the time we're
gonna just go as long as you need um
take your 30 minutes don't worry about
it okay perfect thank you so much
um uh chairman Roy and members of the
criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee
um I'm really happy to be here this
morning
um and hopefully it'll be informative
and I'm happy to be a resource uh
outside of this presentation my name is
Pamela kylig and I'm the public policy
specialist at the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence
um and I have our organization is
um the umbrella Organization for our 12
member programs or our crisis centers
and I'm just happy to speak to you today
about how we work across the state to
address domestic violence sexual assault
human trafficking child abuse and
stalking and I some of you have already
received hopefully um in the mail some
welcome packets for the newly elected
legislators and I have materials for
incumbent legislators as well today that
I'd love to pass out at some point this
morning
so I just wanted to kind of walk through
a little bit about who Our member
programs are the work of the crisis
centers and then the work of the
Coalition and then highlight some key
areas as well as touch on our public
policy work and show how we can be a
resource to you this session in the the
full biennium so just to kind of start
off like I mentioned there are 12 crisis
centers and 11 shelters that provide
services to victims and their families
Statewide they serve nearly 15 000
individuals with direct service support
and provide shelter to around 400 adults
and children annually so we work really
we're embedded in communities and we
work really closely with folks to make
sure that they get the resources and
services they need should they have
experienced any any form of Domestic and
Sexual Violence some of the services
that I just wanted to highlight so you
know sort of what that looks like is
access to confidential advocates
emergency shelter and housing support
including helping find placement in
transitional housing in our rapid
rehousing program as well as providing
shelter for those fleeing violence who
need immediate safety safety is kind of
the umbrella word that we use when we
think about this because we really want
to make sure that anyone who is in these
eminent situations get the help they
need right away
we also provide the crisis centers also
provide funding for immediate basic
needs such as groceries phone cards gas
and rent just to make sure that they
have everything they need for stability
in these situations they also provide
safety planning which is a way to start
making sure that victims and survivors
think through everything they need in
order to stay safe in these situations
for themselves and often their children
we also ensure that they have connection
to Legal Services and this is important
you heard a little bit about the court
system earlier so so helping with filing
protective orders is is a huge service
that our crisis centers provide we also
conduct Hospital advocacy which I'll
touch on a little bit more when I
briefly go over our scene program and
then like I mentioned connection to
Community Resources so they work really
closely with um
different organizations in their
Community to ensure that victims and
survivors have access to Mental Health
Services and other other key services
and again I'm also happy to take
questions as we go to if there's
anything that I can clarify I know it's
a lot of information so please bear with
me
um then kind of putting that into the
context so like I mentioned the
Coalition is the umbrella Organization
for these 12 community-based crisis
centers
um and so we as the Coalition really try
to seek to create safe and just
communities through our Statewide policy
and prevention work
um to really ensure that quality
services are being provided to victims
as well as promote accountability to
societal systems and communities
um and so I think we you know offer
technical uh support to our member
programs help a draft policies for
shelters and things like that to make
sure that we provide standard quality of
care across the state and we also work
with a lot of key Partners including
state agencies advocacy and non-profit
organizations other community resources
and everything to make sure that we are
looping everyone in on these systems to
make sure that it really is a
multi-disciplinary approach and we're
looking at this holistically and so we
also provide a lot of trainings to
different state these some of these
different stakeholders including law
enforcement sometimes the court judges
and the judicial branch state agencies
and so on and so really just trying to
our number one goal is to raise
awareness and really just just um be on
the same page in in terms of how we
won't respond to these issues as a state
um
I think I just wanted to quickly
highlight
the prevention work our same program in
our human trafficking program because
they are very specialized and then just
go over a few other things as well
um so
um so I think prevention is one of the
key things that we really strive to
focus on as a state and I think it's
something that often in the wake of
trying to respond to these really
intense situations we forget how pivotal
prevention is to the work we do and
actually ensuring that we're preventing
violence before it occurs so the
Coalition helps support our Statewide
prevention efforts through providing
technical assistance to our prevention
Educators each crisis center has at
least one prevention educator that works
within the community and sometimes
schools to really try to
build critical skills with the goal of
reducing the risk of intimate partner
violence and child abuse and so they um
it I think teaching like healthy
relationships
um and just identifying signs of abuse
um and really working to
um increa create informed responses in
communities and also strengthening
Community ties and values
um so I think a community response to
prevention education is our ultimate
goal because then we're all really
working together to prevent violence
before it occurs and really
act in the moment when we think
instances of abuse have occurred
um I think another thing that I just
wanted to highlight because we're coming
up to February somehow is that um in New
Hampshire we have Granite State respect
week during teen Dating Violence
awareness month which takes place in
February I'm usually the week of
Valentine's Day and so this is a really
important week-long campaign that we do
within schools and communities to kind
of really raise awareness and you know
try to
um uh support schools and students
through raising awareness promoting
healthy relationships and then of course
connecting teens to really critical
resources in their communities so that
they can get help if they need it
um and I just wanted to highlight that
last year we worked with over 26 schools
and 19 000 students and school
administrators and teachers and so this
is like a huge program that I think is
really important and we're excited to
see it expanding
um and then I just again want to kind of
summarize by just saying prevention
efforts are critical to our ability to
adequately respond to Domestic and
Sexual Violence in New Hampshire
unfortunately research shows that
Domestic and Sexual Violence has lasting
health and financial implications so
again we as a state also have an
economic benefit from intervening
earlier on in these things and can save
a lot of money in the long run on Mental
Health Services substance abuse Services
housing and homelessness services and so
on so we really are excited to have this
opportunity to work with all of you to
hopefully enhance some of these
prevention efforts across the state and
hopefully start limiting the scope of
this issue
um okay sorry I know it's a lot of
information I hope you're also with me
um so kind of Switching gears a little
bit to talk a little bit about some of
the the responses to these issues so we
have the sexual assault nurse examiner
program that sits within the Coalition
and this is the program that helps train
registered nurses to be specialized in
providing trauma-informed care for
sexual assault victims who
yes the same program thank you
um that present to hospitals after an
incident of sexual violence
um and so this is important work we do
across the state with many key
stakeholders through the Attorney
General's office law enforcement
prosecutors and so on and Healthcare
professionals to make sure that we have
standard care across all of our
hospitals and that we are really kind of
maximizing
the probability of collecting and
preserving physical evidence
for the potential use in legal services
legal system so we don't no one has to
move forward but it's just to ensure
that that opportunity is there and that
everything is followed through protocol
and then of course we want to minimize
the physical and psychological trauma to
victims so ultimately first and foremost
is ensuring the health and well-being of
anyone who comes forward with these
issues
um but then making sure that if they
want to they can seek Justice
um and so we provide a lot of trainings
uh throughout the year and there are
currently approximately over a hundred
sane trained nurses um working in New
Hampshire
um and they're located at all 26 of our
acute care hospitals
um and then we also train on average
about 35 new nurses every year so this
is something that we continue to hope
expands and I think are seeing the
co-directors of this program are more
than happy to serve as a resource should
any legislation come forward that might
intersect with these issues
um and
um and also to speak just about you know
sexual assault and sexual violence and
and what that looks like
um and then I think just to for your
information uh roughly 300 to 350
evidence kits are collected every year
in New Hampshire and um about 75 of
those are reported cases
um and the rest are collected
anonymously so again someone who goes to
hospital does not have to file a police
report they don't have to say their name
um they can file it anonymously and then
should they choose to go forward then
that's an option
um so our we really want to make sure
that survivors first and foremost feel
safe that their health and safety is
taken care of and then then support them
if they move forward with legal
proceedings
um another program I just wanted to
quickly highlight is our human
trafficking
um collaborative task force or just the
task force as I'll refer to it kind of
moving forward
um and this is dedicated to improving
the Statewide response to human
trafficking it does also sit within the
Coalition but it consists of a wide
range of stakeholders including the
Department of Justice Homeland Security
investigations State Police the U.S
attorney's Office office Advocates of
our crisis centers human trafficking
survivors and other key stakeholders
throughout the state it actually has
more than a hundred members so again it
really highlights how we really like to
work collaboratively and
multi-disciplinarily if that's a word on
these issues
um and then
um
kind of the the goal is to coordinate
and collaborate to ensure that we have
victim-centered and trauma-informed
approaches and practices and then also
hold offenders accountable we there is
currently
um a protocol being established through
the Attorney General's office and so I'd
be happy to share that once that's
available but that's just a key thing
that we're working on to make sure that
there are a really straightforward and
standard responses to these issues and
so that we can have these collaborative
practices working really smoothly across
the state when we need to respond to
these issues
um and I think another thing that the
task force does is they are really
excited and happy to provide education
through training and Outreach so if this
is an issue that you would like to learn
more about um you can invite them to
come to your community or an
organization to provide
um just inform informative trainings
um they last in 2021 conducted over 46
trainings and reached more than a
thousand participants and unfortunately
this is an issue that is relevant to New
Hampshire I think sometimes we think
about it as a more national issue but
um
put my numbers from
yes human trafficking
um
but so just to give you kind of a
perspective
um victim Advocates from our 12 crisis
centers
um assisted 374 human trafficking
victims between 200 2017 and 2021 and of
those 309 experience sex trafficking and
65 were victims of Labor trafficking so
unfortunately this is something that we
do see in the state and is something
that we're working really hard to
respond to
um and uh we similar to victims of
Domestic and Sexual Violence our crisis
centers provide a lot of similar
services so a similar transitional and
emergency shelter Transportation food
Medical Care Mental Health and
counseling services immigration Aid
translation and language support and so
on so this is something that we really
try to take a human approach to and
really Provide support where it's needed
yeah okay I'm almost there thanks I hope
this is interesting
um so Statewide policy work
um I just wanted to kind of highlight
this because this is kind of why I'm
here and you'll be seeing my face a lot
um hopefully
um I can be a rate a resource to you all
my colleague Amanda who is the director
of public affairs at the Coalition is
also another point of contact for you
all and I'll make sure that you all have
our information should you have any
questions or would like any additional
resources
um moving forward
um we work we again try to work really
collaborative collaboratively with a
variety of stakeholders from State
agencies
um non-profit and advocacy organizations
Health Care Professionals law
enforcement legal representatives and so
on
um as well as survivors and of course
you all
um I think like I kind of have
highlighted
um this is such a intersecting issue and
it impacts so many different things so
it's really important that we engage
with a variety of
individuals to make sure that we fully
understand an issue and how it can
impact someone as well as any policy
Solutions how it will really be
implemented on the ground to ensure that
it's an effective solution
um and I think something that is
exciting about working in this field is
that it's one of the rare issues where
we often have broad bipartisan support
and also tremendous Community Support so
I just really want to take a moment to
thank all of you for the work that you
do to ensure that
um really effective
um positive policies are passed to
support victims across the state
um and I am just grateful to have had
the opportunity to work with some of you
in the past on these issues
um
and I think
um we always again try
um to bring forward any legislation that
has been vetted that we work with
various stakeholders so
um you know we are always open to have
conversations with folks and really make
sure that we're not missing anything and
that it's really going to have a
positive impact
um and again like we're just really
grateful for the work that you do
um so I'm happy to review anything that
you have a question about if you are
wondering if it might have an impact on
victims I like again we are here as a
resource and if we don't know the answer
we will absolutely find someone who can
answer it for you
um and kind of on that note um because
of the critical work
um that you all have done in this
committee
um and and the rest of the legislature
has done we have some of the strongest
protocols in the nation um in laws in
the nation
um and often we are cited as a leader in
advancing
um
Services
improvements and systems and so on for
victims
um and are often cited in actual
National and protocols as a sample of
what we should strive for
um so and we're continuously overhauling
these statutes and rely heavily on this
committee for your support
um so again I'm really excited to just
be a partner in this work
um and I just wanted to highlight I
won't go through all of them but the
Attorney General's office on their
website has a list of protocols that we
have in the state that range from
um you know a model protocol for
responding to child abuse and neglect to
domestic violence protocol calls and so
on and like the like I mentioned the
human trafficking protocol that will be
coming out soon
um and so those model protocols um are a
great resource in terms of looking at
you know what might already be in
statute but then what is already being
practiced on the ground
um and just making sure that everything
kind of um is cohesive and working
together
um and then I also wanted to highlight
um that uh there also was uh the newly
re-established Governor's Commission on
domestic uh violence sexual assault and
stalking
um and so that is another area that we
really hope will help work in um looking
at these policies and identifying what
new laws or statutes need to be revised
and so that's something that we are
excited to be working
um with the the commission on and that's
something that a project that we will be
really taking on this summer and fall to
see if there's anything that we'd like
to put in or that needs to be put in for
next year um so we will definitely keep
you all updated
um as the commission moves forward on
reviewing
um you know policies and and key
statutes um and but we might also be
coming to this committee this year if
there are items are what pieces of
legislation that might be on the agenda
for the commission that we might ask you
to retain or consider holding off until
next year
um just because we really want all of
those stakeholders to have a chance to
really review that legislation and make
sure
um it's a viable policy and I think
because the the commission has prosec um
it has the support of prosecutors
defense attorneys civil legal aid
department of justice department of
safety and so on so it really is again a
broad group of people
um so that was just I kind of just
wanted to plug that for you that that is
a resource for you as well
yes um Senator Carson and Senator Jody
Nelson are on that committee
or the commission yeah so um thank you
that was an important piece I forgot
um
all right so kind of Shifting Gears a
little I just wanted to highlight a few
statistics
um and um areas
um really briefly
um kind of changing the tone a little
bit of the conversation to talk more
about the reality of some of these cases
in the state
um and just kind of talk a little bit
more about what we mean when we say
Domestic and Sexual Violence so
fundamentally it is a pattern of
coercive Behavior used by one person to
gain and maintain power and control over
another in the context of an intimate or
familial relationship
um and so that's kind of where we're
coming from is that it's about power and
control and it's about really
um like looking at that intimate and
familial relationship
um however we have Decades of research
and practice that tells us that there
are ways that we can look at those
Dynamics and understanding those
Dynamics
um that we can learn how to predict a
lethal event
um so
um and I think that's important because
often it's New Hampshire is cited as a
very safe state which it is but
unfortunately the majority of homicides
in the state are domestic violence
related so I think that's a really key
piece to consider when we're looking at
those statistics and we're looking at
what it what it means when we say New
Hampshire is a safe State
um so because there are ways that we can
make the state safer and so
um just uh the uh there's a committee
called the domestic violence fatality
Review Committee and they put out a
report every two years so we are still
waiting on the 20 20 21 report so
unfortunately I only have data from 2018
to 2019.
um but I just wanted to highlight that
21 people lost their lives to domestic
violence homicide in the state during
that time frame and I think there was
recently some an article about how the
homicide rate had actually increased so
I'm we're curious to see sort of where
how that um
how that looks this during the last two
years
um and then I also just kind of wanted
to highlight that unfortunately
um
that means domestic violence is a factor
in more than half of all homicides and
actually 77 percent of all murder
suicides in the state
um so I think while we can talk about I
think that really just puts it in
context when we say safety and we say
that it's addressing the immediate needs
of survivors that's what we mean often
unfortunately we're talking about
life-saving interventions and so that's
why sometimes these policies can be so
pivotal because it's really trying to
prevent the worst case scenario which is
that ultimate lethal event
um
and so I guess kind of like kind of
moving to what we're doing about that I
wanted to highlight The lethality
Assessment program
um which is a way that we can screen
um for these instances
um and just kind of help address those
um so it's a brief intimate Partners
homicide screening tool and accompanying
response and referral protocol for law
enforcement that connects victims in
these circumstances immediately to
crisis center services and so I think
again just highlighting how the
immediate response to these issues is
just really critical
um
and part of that includes safety
planning and making sure that they have
the information and resources that they
need to kind of demonstrate how
important this program is
54 of victims so over three three
thousand individuals from 2018 to 2019
screened in as high danger so this tool
is identifying cases where immediate
services are needed and so these are
kind of areas that we can work together
to when we see policies in legislation
that might be changing how law
enforcement or other Community Partners
and stakeholders are responding to these
issues making sure that we're not
impacting the this immediate response
and making sure that we're ensuring that
these really dangerous situations are
not going to occur
um and then just kind of briefly wanted
to touch on
um and I promise I only have a couple
more things
um I really want to save time for
questions too so
um but I think just really wanted to
highlight again we mentioned uh domestic
violence and stalking protective orders
earlier this morning
um and I just
um from that same report we have
statistics from 2018 to 2019
um to kind of give you a context nearly
8 000 victim victims filed for domestic
violence petitions and uh 4 200 civil
stocking petitions were filed as well
um and then over 75 100 criminal Bill
protective orders were issued in that
time frame um so this is something that
is occurring in our communities and and
requires this response
um yet only 38 of final orders are
granted in domestic violence cases and
part of that is because only 12 percent
of survivors have access to legal
representation in New Hampshire so again
ensuring that
um the like enforcement of protocols and
laws are being adequately made can
really help address some of these issues
and making sure that
when victims are navigating the system
they're getting all the support that
they need
um
and unfortunately that number is even
smaller for stalking victims so I think
it's about five percent actually have
about access to legal representation so
that's a huge area that we really want
to focus on and make sure that folks
have adequate support when they're when
they're engaging in this process and I
think because I think it's important to
say that because I think there's a
misconception that it's easy to get a
restraining order but you can see almost
a third out of the whole picture are the
only ones that get granted a protective
order so the bar is extremely high and
while it's a civil restraining order it
has criminal consequences so I just
wanted to kind of bring that into the
picture
um
and then yeah I'm happy to take any
questions and like I mentioned we are
here to help
um we will always call you back if you
have a question
um and additionally we want like if
there's any questions that constituents
have we're happy to help connect you to
crisis centers make sure that they get
the support they need
um and really help understanding the
services that are available in
communities as well as connect you to
stakeholders and experts
um so I know I kind of covered a wide
range of things
um I could probably do this all day
um so I just really want to make sure
that you know that we're a resource and
we're happy to you know talk through
this one-on-one if you have
um deeper questions
thank you very much and like our
previous speaker it's a very very
important and fascinating area of the
law that we that we touch on
um I just myself have a couple quick
questions
um funding a lot of the stuff you talked
about sounded pretty expensive
um
rent housing food shelter what's your
source of funding
um several source of funding primarily
it is federal but we do have the
domestic violence prevention program
which is through the state budget so
that is something that we will be
addressing this year with the budget
request and so that is about 1.27
million every year and that goes to
Direct Services so managing the crisis
hotline like I mentioned emergency
shelter legal services and so on so
really providing the immediate Direct
Services to survivors okay great okay um
um the same program
do do they also conduct their train to
do the same interviews where where
there's a criminal case if you could
just quickly explain that to the
committee I mean several of us might
know what it is but
yeah so um the same program so in
addition to serving as a resource in
emergency departments where they
primarily operate they also do training
for all Health Care Professionals as
well to make sure that if there isn't a
senior's present they can do that but
these are folks who are especially
trained in the area of sexual assault
and how to actually like not only
document and collect evidence but speak
to that evidence so often they may serve
as Witnesses in court proceedings
um you know expert Witnesses and so on
um and really just help
um
make sure that that process is being
followed they work really closely with
the law enforcement and state lab to
make sure that kits are being processed
and things like that I don't know if I
was thinking more about
in other words when you have a victim
who's a child oftentimes it's very
intimidating to have a room full of
people so the same interviewer would do
yeah and that's one area that we really
am hoping to
on because I think
um all of our scenes are trained in
adult and Adolescent and pediatric care
but that is one area where we hope to
have more specializations right now we
work um most closely with the Laconia
Child Advocacy Center and that was sort
of a pilot program to bring in that work
there and that's something that we're
hoping to see expand across the state
but yes we see unfortunately a lot of
child victims in those cases and say
nurses work really closely to make sure
that
that's all I had for questions
um and the committee has a few
themselves I have to step out to
introduce a bill I just wanted to thank
you so much for coming in and um tell
the members of committee this is a great
resource several years ago I myself had
a bill
um having to do with firearms and the
Coalition advised me that it could be
problematic for some victims I listened
to them I looked into it and they were
absolutely correct and I pulled the bill
so it's very important that you use them
as a resource at least as a to get some
background information on what the
second and third order of effects some
of your bills may have and I'm going to
turn it over to Vice chairman and I have
to step out thank you
foreign
my question was I guess about the woman
who was shot
um I want to say a year two ago by the
person she'd attempted to get a
restraining order against um and it was
rejected and then he shot her a few
weeks later
um I don't want to take up a lot of time
um but as my understanding that there's
some debate as to whether or not the
ruling was in compliance with the law
and since that's we make that loss did
you have any does your organization have
any commentary on that are there any
changes you'd like to see in the law
yeah um a task force was a result of
that incident and there was also a
committee that reviewed
um that as well within the judicial
branch I don't think our friends are
here anymore
um but so and then that was sort of the
basis for what helped re-establish the
governor's commission so that is
something that we are discussing at the
commission to kind of look at closely
and address and I'd be happy to kind of
chat more one-on-one with you to give
you a little bit more information on
that because there is a lot there is a
lot in that discussion in terms of
um just make like how how different
folks have interpreted the law and um
what how that is then playing out in the
courtroom
um so definitely be happy to talk more
I I actually have
um a question that's a follow-up from
chairman Roy he had asked about
about funding and
this is something I actually want to ask
you a lot last year and and I never did
in some states and because we deal so
much with um with fines in in this
Committee in some states the the fines
the actor that money is given to the
domestic violence State program and that
is used
to help reimburse the victim for
um expenses that they have had that
would not have otherwise incurred to
them is that something that New
Hampshire also does so some of them the
money that you do have comes from that
can you explain how that works a little
bit yeah absolutely
um there was a really unfortunate
incident
um that occurred in 2013-2014 where a
young boy was shot and killed during a
supervised visitation and that resulted
in the formation of Joshua's Law and I'd
be happy to talk more about that history
um at a later date but
um basically Joshua's Law resulted in
applying a fee to domestic violence
cases and that goes into a special fund
that crisis centers get I think it's
about forty thousand dollars that gets
split across the crisis centers and that
is really critical funding in terms of
providing the like it's um flexible so a
lot of times it goes to
um you know Medical Care are so really
allows crisis centers to meet the direct
needs of survivors that may not be
available and more restricted funding
from our federal federal grants um so
like replacing locks on doors um
transportation like maybe someone's car
needs to be serviced and they so that
they can you know get to work on
providing child care emergency dental
work is unfortunately something that we
see a lot and so on so Joshua's Law is a
really key resource and I um we have a
little bit more information in terms of
like the variety of services so I'd be
happy to share that with you so you can
see sort of why it is so important
um and so
um that yeah that's something that
started in in 2014 and we are able to
use today okay great
um I actually work at a transitional
shelter it's in Massachusetts as well um
so sometimes we do have people who come
who are in domestic violence situation
um I'm curious especially you know the
way that you were talking about this is
a holistic issue and it interests with a
variety of different things it
absolutely intersects with
um housing and so I was wondering if you
could just kind of give some insight
onto the availability of shelters are
they placed are people placed in um you
know a shelter like mine which is a
transitional shelter that is available
for that or
um you know but does not focus
specifically on that
um are there you know is there is there
availability of specifically domestic
violence shelters and I just wanted to
know kind of how that intersects with
housing and of course we're having you
know shelter beds are short as well yeah
um thank you so much for your question
I'm just gonna flip some stats
um so we like I mentioned so we have 12
crisis centers but we have 11 shelters
in New Hampshire
um the reason being is one of our crisis
centers is co-located at the University
of New Hampshire and so we don't have a
shelter located there but they partner
with
um Haven which is the the closest crisis
center to them should that be a need
um and so our shelters are emergency
shelter so really anyone who is in
imminent danger really fleeing violence
um however
um if the shelter is full
um I want to say there are a hundred and
there are 138 beds available across the
state and like I mentioned we shelter
around 400 adults and children every
year
um and or who are in shelter and I think
there's kind of a lot of things so I
definitely love to talk more with you
about it because it's kind of a deep
issue
um but I think the key thing is when
someone is an emergency shelter the
immediate next step is to try to see how
we can support them in accessing
transitional or permanent housing so
that we can make sure that more people
can cycle through the shelter as needed
so we have our transitional housing
program and our rapid rehousing program
and we're also part of the the Bureau of
housing supports continue of Continuum
of Care so we do a lot of work across
the state to look at different housing
options
um and just making that available I
think again there are Emergency Shelters
so there may be
um a domestic violence victim who has
been removed from that um situation and
maybe like several years down the road
may have access to a a non-emergency
shelter
um but I'd be happy to talk more about
those Dynamics and because it's a really
oh representative Reed
so I've been hearing that there's a
Department
yeah no thank you for that question I'm
sorry the and I can't see you very well
but um so to
um kind of address that really quickly
um there actually is now a tracking
system so the the sexual assault
Advisory board and the state lab worked
on uh getting a grant to help sort of
expedite that process and now all new
kits um it started with a pilot program
in certain hospitals but now Statewide
they're slowly rolling out all kits that
will have a USB code on it
um so that they can track
um the kit process and have a better
ability to make sure that things are
moving through the system and I know
that they've made significant progress
on that backlog
um and so again like um I think it's
kind of a complex issue so I'd be happy
to chat with you more about that and
just give you a little bit more insight
thank you
thank you I have a couple of quick
questions you spoke of a handout
will that have something I don't know
about the same program is that it
referred to in your handout um I didn't
include
I'd sure like it the other the other
question is more General are you a
growth industry or are is this
increasing or are we getting a
getting this problem under control this
is very your presentation is very
discouraging sorry
um yeah that's a great question and
unfortunately I don't have a
straightforward answer
um we um
one of the issues that the commission
the governor's commission is also trying
to look at is our Statewide data and
tracking
um
systems right now a lot of that isn't
um collaborative so I know what like the
number of victims that we serve through
our crisis centers and that's the
picture that I have but unfortunately we
don't have a full picture on the true
scope of it because
um as much as we wish every everyone
would come to our crisis center is that
unfortunately isn't the case so we only
serve probably unfortunately a small
portion of those who really need
Services
um and so um and that's why you all can
be a great help in making sure that
folks get referred um to your local
crisis center um but I think that's
that's an issue that the commission is
really trying to tackle to get a better
sense of the full scope of the issue I
think there's a lot of things that we
have made significant progress on and a
lot of that is due to the laws and
protocols that have been established
with support of this committee and the
legislature
um but I think then you know there's
always more work that unfortunately
needs to be done in terms of raising
awareness and identifying these issues
yep
you're pretty good
all right
very informative thank you very much for
joining us today
uh so we
um
I've had a couple of people ask if we
could just take five minutes so we're
going to recess for for five minutes and
then whenever we come back we are going
to hear from commissioner Hanks
um
all right everybody we're going to be
okay
tonight
do you have one for Amy okay
all right this time we will resume our
orientation for the criminal justice
welcome
thank you
good morning my name is Helen Hanks I am
the commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections I've had the
privilege to be in state service I'm in
my 20th year
I was honored to be nominated as
commissioner in November of 2017 and
served a four-year term and was
re-nominated and confirmed in October of
2021. I share that with you because I
think it gives you a depth of awareness
of my time with the department and that
I spent most of the beginnings of my
career managing the medical and forensic
services that we deliver across the
department and then changed that role in
2014 when I was the assistant
commissioner
uh there will be a con constant theme
you've heard this morning at least from
the Judiciary to the department our
number one challenge at the agency is
Staffing remains to be Staffing
primarily our Corrections Officers but
also our nursing staff and our mental
health clinicians I've provided a
PowerPoint that should be each of your
locations and we'll send that out
electronically as well and advise you
that our last published annual report of
fy21 is a robust document that is
intended to tell you a lot more than I
can tell you in the time that I'll have
here with you today specifically in the
diversity of treatment and programming
and other data points that you may find
relevant and if you don't find it in
there to my right is Jane Graham our
departmental legislative liaison and
she'll help and I will help navigate
your request and we'll make sure you
have our contact information
we rebranded our vision as an agency on
the first page of the PowerPoint because
they think it's important that our goal
is to have a fully staffed Workforce
where everyone is professionally
developed and yes we do expect that
individuals who are in our care and
custody are provided an opportunity for
Progressive Rehabilitation and we do
want state-of-the-art facilities in in
order to do that
on the following page I provide really
just some images of the different
facilities that we run I do want to make
it clear for members the Department of
Corrections the New Hampshire Department
of Corrections does not have oversight
of the county jails those are distinctly
managed by each County and they have a
county superintendent and a county
delegation so if you have a County Jail
question please see your county and they
will assist you the county
superintendents do have an association
and superintendent Chris Brackett is
their currently elected president and
I'm sure he can assist in your county
jail questions
I cannot
uh the New Hampshire state prison for
men which is our largest facilities here
in Concord its foundation is as old as
1878.
1878. that is an important number we ask
every year for a significant portion of
the capital budget appropriation to
maintain that facility it is designed in
a campus style format it is the least
efficient format to manage in a
correctional facility it is a challenge
with our challenge in Staffing it is a
challenge just based on the age of the
infrastructure I don't want to take away
there is some really interesting
Correctional infrastructure there and
yes if we're fortunate enough My Hope Is
that you will support in building a new
facility we can turn it into a museum
because there are sections that
definitely belong in a museum
especially the rats
um
we built a new facility for women we had
leased a facility in Goffstown we were
fortunate to move into that facility in
April of 2018 with final construction
elements that occurred and were
completed that literally the Public
Works checklist in 2019 all of these
facilities we would certainly open up a
tour opportunity to any member of the
legislature we will put you through a
criminal background check and other
elements that we put everyone through so
bear with us as we go through that
process we run prisons
we have three transitional housing units
that are one is in Manchester two are
here in Concord one of the facilities in
Concord is dedicated to women and we
have one transitional work center for
men here in Concord the transitional
work Center for Women was built on the
campus of the new correctional facility
for women and again I think seeing the
Men's prison first and the women's
prison last will give you a good sense
of the differences in Correctional
design
on the following page I just I think
it's important we've had these
conversations with previous members of
the legislature and I will expect that
new members of the legislature will ask
these questions going forward to give
you a base information of the
self-reported it is self-reported race
collected at a time of booking it is
mostly a group of white Caucasian
individuals incarcerated in our
facilities our census in the prisons
on the following page we incarcerate
mostly biological men sorry men in the
room
um 93 of the people incarcerated are
males uh biological males in the state
of New Hampshire our census for women
was as low as I think it was a hundred
yesterday
um and we built the facility that I
referenced to the capacity of 224. at
the time that that facility was
authorized through the capital budget
appropriation process there was a plan
to ensure that we could increase the
capacity there and I'm happy that we
have never had to come back and ask to
increase the capacity at that women's
prison and and hence we're using half of
it
on the following page I give you and I
can provide these by gender I did it as
a higher overview cognizant that we
wouldn't have a lot of time I could
spend probably eight hours just giving
you a historical education a current
educational Corrections it is my passion
but these are the age ranges of the
people uh the adults that are under our
care and custody and you'll see that
mostly they're between the ages of 30
and 49.
we do not have any uh adjudicated minors
those adjudicated minors would be in the
care and custody of the Youth Detention
Center until they turned the age of 18
at which time we would take over custody
of them because of the prison rape
elimination act that came from the
federal government we did change the law
to assure we were compliant with that I
do want you to know that term prison
rape elimination act because as a
correctional agency we have to pass an
audit of three sites every year if we do
not we affect the state's ability to
receive Federal grant funding so we take
that charge seriously and have passed
our audit and we like to tell the state
of New Jersey we were the first to pass
the federal prison rape elimination act
when it started uh I think it was 2016
and we're still in a debate with New
Jersey
which we will win on The Following pages
are the basic crime breakouts if I gave
you a chart of all of the RSA violations
it would simply tell you that one-third
of the men in New Hampshire who are
incarcerated adult males are
incarcerated for violations associated
with sex sexual assault aggravated
sexual assault felonious sexual assault
one-third of the population of men
incarcerated in New Hampshire fit that
fit that criteria they're in the section
of the 64 percent personal uh personal
includes violent also in that largest
blue bar on that Circle are attempted
murder murder things of that nature
those violent volatile crimes
approximately 600 people are
incarcerated associated with violations
under the controlled Drug Act so when
our partners the Judiciary were talking
about mental health courts the other
implementation of Statewide drug court
has made a large and positive impact on
reducing individuals incarceration
associated with substance use disorder
as well as their mental health courts
with individuals with severe and
persistent mental illness so we love
drug court the department loves mental
health court and I know there are a few
veterans courts and we greatly
appreciate those opportunities that the
Judiciary has created to divert people
from incarceration if it's safe for
Public Safety
on the following slide I think another
important area is to talk about the
population of those incarcerated New
Hampshire has been proactive proactive
as far back as 2014 and we've seen a 26
percent decline in the incarcerated
population in the state of New Hampshire
the adult population and that is because
of the things they just referenced the
implementation of state right why drug
court looking at mental illness as a
root of the criminogenic behavior and
can there be other Alternatives that can
be safely managed through whether it's
probation diversion in general or other
opportunities if it is again at the
advantage of of it doesn't affect uh
adversely excuse me Public Safety Public
Safety is the most important aspect and
if it can't be managed that way then the
sentence structure will result in an
we are also thankful that the population
decreased because our staffing decreased
and we were able to shut down the second
floor of a large general population
housing unit back in July of 2021 that
reduced our post requirements at the
Men's prison by 14. that's significant
we also shut down a 56 bed general
population unit at Women's and reduced
that security post requirement by five
daily so you add that over time without
those reductions with the reduction of
our staffing we've had a very
challenging last several years
on the following slide after the
population reduction I I did show you on
purpose the population by maximum
sentence because in New Hampshire we
have a minimum sentence and a maximum
sentence that minimum sentence minimum
parole release date is never a guarantee
but this maximum is a guarantee
the DV the part I footnote at the bottom
is it doesn't account for people's
consecutive sentence because someone can
be incarcerated on multiple consecutive
sentences and we can't possibly
calculate that because we don't know
when they're going to achieve parole to
that we don't know when they're going to
achieve parole to that consecutive
sentence so this is the best Snapchat we
can give you with some consistency and
Staffing challenges I told you we were
going to talk about that on the
following Slide
the security vacancy rate in October was
39 percent it's closer to 50 percent
today and I'm talking specifically in
the area of Corrections Officers I'm not
talking when I say 50 I'm not talking
about Corporal sergeants lieutenants
captains we have a whole Rank and file
within our organization it's Corrections
Officers I heard someone reference and I
think it was the clerk from Concord say
that Amazon's offering twenty dollars an
hour the department of corrections as a
starting corrections officer offers just
under 22 dollars an hour when we ask
people to work in a prison from 1878 24
hours a day with individuals who
committed felonies a majority of them
sex offenders so my charges
Commissioners try to rectify that
minimum starting Baseline and advocate
for a change for our Corrections
Officers and trying to draw in qualified
candidates who are expected to maintain
Humane supervision and Security in our
24 hour seven day a week Correctional
Institution
another unique area that people don't
think about corrections is really a
community of all professionals behind a
brick wall with razor wire we need chefs
we need clinicians we need case managers
we need clerical support we need it just
as the community needs it we need
recreational therapists but we're having
a hard time also recruiting chefs to
help manage our kitchens and we're
fortunate to have residents who want to
work in our kitchens but we do need
chefs to help manage the quality and
delivery of those Food Service the other
area that is not uncommon and many of
you both professionally and through your
legislative experience is the area of
registered nurses and other nursing
disciplines we have a 27 vacancy rate in
that area and then mental health
clinicians we are competing with
everybody who needs a mental health
clinician licensed alcohol drug
counselor clinical mental health
counselor licensed social worker we are
competing with our community mental
health centers our emergency rooms you
name it we're competing with them and we
have a 38 vacancy in those positions as
well
really positive presentation I know
well the fortunate part for the state is
the Department of Corrections we
Endeavor to persevere and maybe to our
own deficit but we persevere every day
and I have some of the strongest most
dedicated Correctional staff that I
could ask for in the state could ask for
so I just want to take a minute to
appreciate them I show you the Staffing
Trends on the next following pages I
break out security staff versus what we
call our civilian staff those other
people not wearing the corrections
uniform on a daily basis and you should
you should notice on FY 22 we experience
like many other people experience coming
out of the height of covid a mass Exodus
of individuals who deservedly retired
they had greater than 20 plus years of
Correctional experience and said wow
those were the toughest two years of my
life I'm gonna go do something else and
I shook their hand and thanked them for
their service
we have hired to date just the update at
the end 17 corrections officer training
these that number is too small but we
continue to persevere again in different
unique ways than we have in the past as
a Corrections agency and I'll talk about
those moving into my next slide
so if you know somebody who's interested
in Corrections we will give them a tour
we will hire them if they meet the
minimum standards and we will give them
a long and enduring career so please
refer them to my department
on the following slide civilian Staffing
Trends it did the same thing in FY 22 as
far as the retirement and really
actually people choosing theirs was a
little different that column called
termed doesn't mean we asked them to
leave it means they separated or
terminated their relationship with us
that demonstrates the competitive
competitiveness of community people or
organizations who are recruiting our
employees to go work in their
organizations at a higher rate of pay
with a lot less stress than you would
experience in a correctional environment
and we do a lot of exit interviewing so
we learned a lot over the last several
years about what we can do differently
and what we hope to do going forward to
help retain people because as much as
recruiting people is important where
attention as equally and critically as
important
uh the following slide shows the ratio
of our staff's biological gender to
their years of service
we have really increased the number of
biological women who work for us I think
that's a benefit to creating a unique
and equalized working environment we
have a very ethnically diverse work
um work
excuse me Staffing I just I'm very
impressed with the number of people who
come and work in our agency whether
their original origins or Russia or
Uganda you name it we have such a
wonderfully Diverse
Staffing Cadre so I just thought this
would be helpful the average years of
service is nine and a half years at
least it was when I ran this in October
that is different in my time with the
agency where that number had been closer
to 15. I'm not judging that as a
negative situation but it is nice to
know that the average years of service
is nine and a half years once we can get
people after that first and third year
to stay
recruiting events we have made numerous
adjustments this is just a snapshot of
the places that we have gone to attempt
to recruit people into this mystery
called Corrections and we go to high
schools we go to colleges we bring them
in we take them on tours we have created
a temporary full-time recruiting
Sergeant for their for our whole
organization we're going to increase
that to two we do think that and found
that getting our faces out there to talk
about what Corrections is what it isn't
we are not a reality TV show we are much
more
polished professional and interesting
than that and then I think it was
important to also show you that our
source of hire is generally our staff or
other state employees that's been
helpful to know and that our recruitment
team is drawing in about two percent and
that's a new initiative so that's a new
slice of the pie we weren't aware of if
you don't follow us we're probably on
every social media you could possibly
imagine even ones I didn't know existed
but now I do so good for me
um and we published numerous things both
to recognize our staff unique things
about corrections and programs and
things that we're doing within the
agency so I would suggest just follow us
it'll be interesting I promise you
um we talked I talked a lot about what
happens or at least our incarcerated
population but the other part of the
agency is the division of field services
that is our probation and parole
Services probation is time served on
probation parole is time served after
you've achieved your privilege of
release on your minimum sentence those
are the two distinct differences if you
violate probation that time on probation
does not count toward the sentence of
violation of paration you start again
um the area of field services is also a
collections agency so if you didn't know
the Department of Corrections has a
collections agency and we collect the
court fines and restitution associated
with felony level crime as well as
obligations Financial Obligations that
people incur through the destruction of
state property during their incarcerated
stay
the probation and parole team also
supervises interstate compact agreement
so if you did not know almost all 50
states are part of a federal commission
that actually allows people to transfer
their supervision after application and
vetting by the receiving state to have
their parole supervised and generally it
was their home state so most people do
not receive the opportunity to have
their Supervision in New Hampshire if
they're applying from another state if
they do not have a grounded family or
support system in our state that's
square one of the application process
and administrative home confinement is a
form of privileged incarceration at home
with GPS monitoring that goes through
the statutory process that starts
um evaluating if they've done
rehabilitative programming if they have
an appropriate housing situation and
supports they have the likelihood of
attaining a job or have a job offer and
or are enrolled in an educational
program then I will recommend them for
administrative home confinement and that
recommendation goes before the
sentencing judge and the sentencing
judge and the prosecuting attorney and
defense attorney have time by Statute to
comment before the ultimately affirming
my recommendation or declining it we've
used that in the highest point 33 cases
I think we have nine people today out on
administrative home confinement it's not
a highly used form of release
primarily because housing is an issue
finding appropriate housing and stable
housing is a barrier to the use of
administrative home confinement as a fun
fact I will let you know that the
governor's Commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs
funded a housing program for the
Judiciary and Corrections and Drug Court
participants it's a fun fact because
it's strange that the Judiciary is
running a housing program for
Corrections and Drug Court participants
and was nationally recognized in a drug
court conference across the country and
other states are now looking at that
program and through the support of the
lead Rachel who is over at the Judiciary
she's helped house over 400 people
post-release from incarceration or
participating in drug court and that's
really important because those 400
people could have ended back at the
prison and we really don't want people
to come back
the field services caseloid as our
incarcerated population has also been
decreasing so that's what the following
slide starts to show you the blue line
is probation so the most number of
people out on Community Supervision is
probation that orange line is parole
supervision you're going to see new
elements in the FY 22 and um and FY 23
and those are to denote the inclusion of
fugitives people who have absconded from
supervision the other bar graphs going
back further they're embedded in either
probation or parole and we really wanted
to give a clean lens on who we're
supervising in New Hampshire that we
know where they are and that we know we
don't know where some people are simply
said and you'll see that conversation I
had about administrative home
confinement that's the smallest number
across those years
and then the New Hampshire
non-supervised is that interstate
compact conversation I had with you a
moment ago
so good things are happening we're using
less of the incarcerated system and less
of the supervision system in New
Hampshire so we have to be doing
something right now I haven't done the
full analysis and it would be
interesting to do one to see what have
we been doing right over the last 10
years above and beyond what I stated
because we are doing something right we
do several things right but it's
happening also in this area on the
following slide when I when I took on
the responsibility of commissioner I
include this slide as simple as Vehicles
because as simple as vehicles our agency
needs the resources to do the things
I've talked about and our probation and
parole officers have been under
outfitted with vehicles so I've spent
from 2017 to today within our existing
budget to increase their Fleet from 19
to 23. and it may not seem like a lot
but it is enough it's and it's going to
keep heading in that direction because
you can't send people out in the
community to supervise if you don't have
a vehicle to go do it in
it's just reality the other thing I
started working on is actually
increasing their caseload and you'll see
on the narrative on the car slide I talk
about not increasing their caseload
increasing the staff to facilitate their
caseload so in the budgeting process
um in 18 I asked for four new probation
parole officers I was fortunate to
attain uh two and we deployed those to
equalize the ratio of Probation and
Parole offices to the cases that they
were managing in looking at the agency's
vacancy because in the next budgeting
phase it really wasn't a time to ask for
new staff so I looked at our existing
long-term vacancies and made a decision
to use the Personnel process to take
those vacancies and turn those into
additional probation and parole officers
so what you'll see is the ratio
adjustments that occurred on the
following slide deck to help create us
more in line with the National Institute
of Corrections standards for probation
and parole supervision so we're making
strides in the right direction so that
we have proper supervision levels out in
the community
and then recidivism if that is a new
word for you it is a fancy word to say
that three years after their release
from incarceration they came back to New
Hampshire incarceration we don't like
high recidivism numbers but we have to
understand what they are if we're going
to make a difference in helping people
stay in New Hampshire communities
so if you look at 2018 from 2017
there are things we know were going on
in the state of New Hampshire and that
is the opioid epidemic our individuals
are affected by substance use disorder
at a higher rate than the average
neighbor citizen person in New Hampshire
and we saw the rate for men increase
significantly as far as recidivism in
2018 because that's three years after
they left so they left in 2018 when we
watched them for three years after that
you might ask me commissioner why did
the women's number not go up why did it
go down we were fortunate to receive
state opioid response dollars from our
partners at Health and Human Services to
deploy a pilot project and that project
was to partner people voluntarily
post-release with what we coined a
re-entry care coordinator and they
followed women who had opioid use
disorder one year post-release and
functioned as I would equate it to a
health care Navigator a navigator to
remove barriers and help them connect to
whatever resources are going to help
stabilize them in the community whether
it's treatment provider were they having
challenges with housing do we need to
help have navigate daycare and it made
them it made a difference and it
continued to make a difference so in
2019 we were provided an opportunity to
add two more re-entry care coordinators
through the same funding for men so as I
continue to look at our recidivism
numbers I expect that number to be
better but we are still challenged with
substance use disorder and its impacts
on individuals who were supervising out
in the community and the small little
chart below I'll send this to you
electronically so you can read tiny
little writing underneath
are the hearings outcome from our Adult
Parole Board I'll also take this
opportunity to tell you I do not
supervise the adult parole award The
Adult Parole Board is managed out of the
governor's office and is a separate
partner for the agency to Nutri as a
neutral party to examine the
opportunities to Grant privileges of
parole or violations of parole and in
their review of cases the bar chart
underneath shows that the reasons people
violate parole in the top three are
issues associated with drug and alcohol
use so I don't think that should be
surprising but it's an area we have to
continue to Target and then the third
rule violation has to do with unstable
housing unstable employment and moving
throughout the state it's all it's
almost always a combination of these
rule violations it's not generally just
one if it is generally just one it's
because they've engaged in actual
additional criminal
criminal contact or criminal engagement
in the community and they've been
arrested
what I would hope you would go to the
annual report and learn more about but
here's a little snapshot of pictures of
things we've done to implement new
programming called Choose Love we've
taken what's been deployed in our our
school systems in New Hampshire worked
with the partners to afford it um and
equal it to an adult learning curricula
and it's been well received and made a
really wonderful impact with women we
started with women first and now we've
deployed it to our men's programming
gives you an a summary ctec is our
Career and Technical education center we
are part of the correctional
organizations who have been approved and
have partners for the reauthorization of
the second chance Pell grant that will
start in July 1 our Technical Community
Partners are White Mountain Community
College and nhti here in Concord so
we'll continue down that road
I only have two more to go victim
services but you didn't know we had a
victim Services Bureau but we do we
support uh victims and survivors of
felony level crime here in New Hampshire
and this is a summary we are on the cusp
of deploying and being part of the vine
automated notification system that many
of our County Jail Partners have already
had we did that through our federal
funding for victim services so that will
be moving forward and making it really a
self-service model how you want to be
notified about that person who's
affected your life email phone call text
you name it if you want a hard copy
letter you'll still get that and the
following slide is to give you a sense
in one month there are thousands of
individuals who are supporting whether
it's supporting through victim our
Bureau victim Services whether the
person is incarcerated probation or
parole so we do that across the gamut uh
and I did put that we've collected 1.1
million dollars in restitution and
obligations at the time of uh publishing
this PowerPoint and then on that last
slide is my media marketing attempt to
tell you please follow us on all these
social media platforms
I thank you for your patience it's been
a long morning and happy to answer
questions and or follow up with you
because this was just a snapshot of what
we do
thank you commissioner Hanks you
obviously put a lot of effort into this
and we really appreciate your time and
the information I haven't been on this
committee and served for a few years now
I I really appreciate the Innovative
methods you've taken to help these folks
get get on the straight path thank you
sir
um
I'd be interested in talking to you
later about setting up a field trip
um for any of the members of the
committee who would like to go and take
a tour and see what's going on at both
the men's and women's facilities so that
we have an idea and can actually see the
people that these laws affect and impact
um just a couple quick questions I have
um your recruitment I noticed on the
list of colleges you didn't have any
state schools do you go to UNH do you
have any issues with the state schools
getting in there or anything like that
that was just uh thank you for that
question that was just a short list we
go to UNH okay you name it we're trying
to be there we also work with our
partners at Employment Security as well
okay
um and I've asked us a couple of other
presenters how's the homeless situation
in this state impacting uh I mean are
some people not having difficulty
leaving the system because they have
nowhere to go I mean do you see people
coming into the system that are there
for crimes that really they just needed
a place to live that's
uh housing program we've partnered with
the Judiciary has helped us on the
helping prevent people's return but also
helping find stable housing because it's
not just here's your housing for a
couple of months and we walk away we the
program is designed to give you housing
and then long-term housing stability so
I think we've been really fortunate to
be able to Pilot and continue to receive
funding for that program we actually
asked for more money from the governor's
commission that was granted to us to
continue to expand that opportunity with
that said I will tell you we do not
automatically violate someone's
probation and or parole if they lose
their housing we do not want the state
corrections agency to be the default
housing we will only look to violations
if it's associated with Public Safety
around crime criminal activity
significant substance use relapse so I
can't solidly answer your other question
about community-based homelessness other
than say that the you'll see Corrections
at what you wouldn't expect in the
community I was recently at the city of
concord's collaborative discussion on
homelessness specifically in Concord
you'll see the commissioner Corrections
at meetings on education you'll see us
at treatment because we have all of
those issues but it's a it's a
challenging question I mean housing is
hard for the person who's working every
day not involved in the justice system
I agree thank you thank you any
questions
oh we have a lot okay uh representative
Muse
I just wanted a quick update on where we
stand with the secure psychiatric unit
yeah thank you for that question
representative Muse we continue to
function under the existing statute the
department does operate the secure
psychiatric unit it is a mix of
individuals not mixed in their housing
but a mix of services for people who are
civilly committed under specific
statutes and those who have exceeded our
capacity to support them in our regular
prison environment so it's a mix of
sentenced adults and civilly committed
individuals the latter that being
sentenced adult is actually the primary
population we treat in the secure
psychiatric unit but we are poised to
hand over everybody civilly committed as
soon as the new forensic hospital is
built and I don't have a clear timeline
on when that's happening but I I do
think it's important to share with this
committee the secure psychiatric unit
that the Department of Corrections runs
the service need for Corrections won't
go away so we'll still use that building
and embedded in that building in a
separate Wing is the residential
treatment unit which provides for up to
40 adult males opportunity for treatment
for their mental illness so it's a
complex building that will continue to
use once the forensic hospital is built
and HHS takes that portion over I will
look to our partners over at HHS to send
you a timeline representative Muse
um I just had to interject with a
question and I forgot to ask
um regarding the opioid crisis you get
handed a lot of individuals who are
currently addicted how do you deal with
that
um getting them the medical help
obviously they're going to need when
they're coming off of these drugs how is
that working out and the challenges
around that if you just could briefly
that question that's an important
question individuals who come uh to our
department who upon booking our officers
are trained to identify but in the first
short hours that someone's there a
member of our nursing team also triages
we triage for suicidality symptoms of
detox things of that nature we have
medical professionals who work for us
who work with our nursing staff to
provide medically monitored
detoxification in our infirmary spaces I
want to make it clear what I say
infirmary I am not a hospital if
somebody needs Hospital level of care we
take them to the hospital but infirmary
is more for pre-post-op or things we can
manage and we know we can safely manage
in our infirmary settings so we've had
since prior to 2011 medically assisted
detoxification we also have a robust
treatment for people with opioid use
disorder through medication we are not
licensed to dispense methadone but we
have all the other methods of medication
and when we primarily use methadone it's
with women who are pregnant and have
opioid use disorder and we work with a
partnering agency to facilitate that but
we have buprenorphine now
trexon naloxone we do Narcan we do all
of those things we do the injectables
and I've been very proud that the
agency's been ahead of that and can we
continue to advance and I would also say
that the recently published federal act
that removed the waiver requirements for
providers and the patient caps on
caseloads has been a game changer for
Corrections and will really help us
increase our capacity to treat those
with opioid use disorder we have
hundreds of individuals who are
receiving medications associated with
treating opioid use disorder today
thanks
there we got it thank you
um I have two questions if that's okay
um so the first is that um uh Jester
Justice Broderick has in many speeches
talked about how our prison system is
probably the greatest provider of Mental
Health Care
um I'm wondering whether you see a
pathway to avoid the need for the
correctional system if there were better
access to mental health care in some
capacity that's my first question yeah
thank you for that and I've actually
heard him talk and and he and I talk
frequently the department
says this you heard me I support Drug
Court mental health court I expect that
that diversion opportunity is vetted at
that level
um but we also and will provide the
mental health treatment for people who
have been deemed that despite having a
mental health disorder their
criminogenic issues are so significant
they need incarceration for us we look
to what can we do to reduce the person
returning and then learn about other
things the state could Implement on that
diversion side so with that I would also
share with you that actually sit on a
committee through the Judiciary and our
chief justice to look at other
opportunities that we might not be
exploring as a state with other
collaborative Partners including a
retired Nami leader Ken Norton and
others to say what else can we do that
we haven't flipped that stone over and I
do think housing is important housing is
so important that we have to overcome
that as a state-based issue
let me ask my second okay okay
um so my my second question actually has
to do with housing and employment so
um to what extent do you partner
organizations for housing and employment
for people who have served time for
felonies because I know at least in the
county level
finding places that are willing to
accept
um people who serve time to either for
employment or housing is incredibly
difficult that's a great question and
again I already referenced the program
we started in 2018 but I also on behalf
of the governor chair the Commission on
mental illness and the corrections
system and with that the New Hampshire
Housing Authority Rod Rob he sits on
that commission and a lot of things
we're talking about that we can all
participate in
um whether whatever your investment is
is on the federal restrictions around
affordable housing that almost
automatically exclude people from using
those opportunities those those are in
print and then there are your local
housing regulations that the state
doesn't peel down into and you as
leaders in your areas can work at a
local level to try to peel some of those
back and invite us to come to your
communities to talk about
what they the myths of including those
prevent because having people at risk
who are homeless only makes them more at
risk
um so there are things we can do locally
that we have control over that remove
exclusions from affordable housing
locally I'm cognizant to say that I
already said housing is an issue for
people who aren't even Justice involved
so when Justice involved people are
competing for that same housing
who's going to win
and the Department of Corrections does
not want to run apartment buildings we
want to stay where we belong a partner
with the people who should be running
those apartment buildings houses
townhouses I don't mean to imply that
people coming out of Corrections should
only be in an apartment but housing is
so critical
foreign
first of all I am so happy to hear you
say that the Mad Act is a game changer
because I was one of a whole bunch of
people who advocated for that and was
very happy to see that passed thank you
part of the Omnibus
um absolutely I'm I'm I'm going to share
that I hope you don't mind I guess I'll
ask right now yes
um I also I'm a homeless Advocate I work
at a homeless shelter a transitional
homeless shelter I'm sure you were
sitting here so you heard that before
um what I'm curious about is you know we
provide kind of wraparound Services
number one is that part of the Judiciary
funded program the housing program
number two uh what kind of resources uh
wraparon services are available to
people and I'm curious I'm sorry it's
three-part question I guess I'm curious
about the length of stay average length
of stay an incarcerated stay yeah okay
so your three-part question I'm sorry
that's okay a lot no I will send you a
copy of the document that outlines what
we do with the Judiciary because it does
talk in detail about the wraparound
services and then everybody will have
that information and I think that's also
the reason it's been successful we the
agency provide case managers and other
service individuals depending on the
person to help re-entry plan for
everyone departing Corrections and I
will also take my commissioner pitch to
say Medicaid expansion was a game
changer in 2014 that individuals prior
to that leaving Corrections we wrapped
all of these services and we're not
cheap we're general fund Dollars around
a person and they had no insurance
connectivity to maintain those services
so when authorization happened in August
of 2014 we had a pathway to continue
people's medication we had a pathway to
find them a primary care provider we had
a pathway to intervene to reduce or
intervene and make sure people don't
come back to incarceration
um so everything we can do to stabilize
people and I've worked with director
Littman Henry Littman who's our director
of Medicaid
to make sure that Justice involved
persons are still part of that
conversation so please reauthorize
Medicaid expansion uh Corrections is
begging you to do that the other part
that becomes important uh
and relative to your question is the
state requested from the federal
government an addition in our Medicaid
waiver this time around and it was to
Target Services 45 days prior to the
date of release and those services that
we're hoping the federal government will
agree with us are to reduce people's use
of emergency room services and other
crisis Services because we're asking for
them to cover Through Medicaid dollars
an appointment with a peer-to-peer
recovery specialist an appointment with
the First with their first primary care
whatever that Primary Care is if it's a
psychiatrist or psychiatric nurse
practitioner or if it's their general
practitioner we want to get that
face-to-face started because there's one
thing about human beings if we meet the
person we're supposed to go see in 30
days we actually have this thing called
guilt if we don't show up so that's
Incorporated in the state's Medicaid
waiver it went through a lot of support
from State partners that I didn't even
anticipate and then the federal
government has looked at our waiver so
we're literally just waiting from an
answer from the centers of Medicaid and
Medicare services so that's also my
pitch to say please reach out to our
federal Partners ask them to support New
Hampshire's 1115 a waiver and I'll also
make sure you get a copy of it we're
trying to build those bridges to reduce
people's return and to really wrap
services around and our expectation is
it could happen face to face but we're
also practical it's likely those are
going to happen in a Telehealth type
encounter
third part was average like the state oh
I almost had it thank you sir it used to
be three and a half to seven years was
the average sentence structure that has
increased a bit it's now looking more
like it's five to ten but I'm going to
go back to what I said before a lot of
that is because we have a lot of men
incarcerated for violations of sexual
assault
with that I will tell you that the
provisions afforded people under the
earn time Credit Law do have a positive
rehability impact both on them and their
sentence structure and when the judges
check the box on the sentencing Minimus
that give them that opportunity it
starts to adjust that minimum and
maximum depending on the person's
investment in real rehabilitative
programming
thank you Mr chairman I just had a
question about the prison environment
and I wonder if you could go into a
little bit about what the environment of
these three prisons are and is it calm
is it dangerous and violent what is the
environment in the prison's like
representative wheeler that is a complex
question
I would say that the environment is
dependent on which unit you're housed on
and here's why we've purposely created
some modified therapeutic communities
and taken over whole housing units and
said if you want to voluntarily go live
on this Wellness unit because you're all
74 of you are invested in your own
Wellness the quality of culture on that
unit is different they're already
self-motivated and when you go on that
unit which I hope you have an
opportunity to do so they'll actually
they say to me commissioner it's a
little weird in here I don't I don't
want to scare you but I don't feel like
I'm in prison and I said I'm glad you
don't because I I need us all to
remember you have a second chance on
life and we need you to think about your
future and then we have other programs
called the focus unit it is not an
acronym not an acronym it's capital F it
is a modified Therapeutic Community that
targets substance use disorder climate
on that's a little differently yes
they're motivated to be there but we've
actually in some instances held back
disciplinary infractions and said we
want to highly motivate you to go there
so you have some people who raise their
hand and some people who avoid
disciplinary infractions to go there so
it's still therapeutic but a different
environment and we also have the realism
that we literally have security threat
groups in our institutions also known as
gangs who we are trying to thwart their
criminal conduct within our Correctional
environment so to your question is it
dangerous yes it can be incredibly
dangerous is every day incredibly
dangerous it has the potential to be
dangerous and one of the highest
diverted pieces of Contraband right now
is
fentanyl laced paper and paper that has
been soaked in synthetic cannabinoids
and we also found paper soaked in
cocaine and so our staff at Corrections
in our mail room have personal
protective equipment not just because of
covid-19 but because we're asking them
the touch paper we went to photocopying
I will call Casual mail and now we have
to figure out what to do with legal mail
because Contraband legal mail is the
other venue which we're experiencing so
I give you a flavor of that because it
depends on where you are in the
organization in the institutions
um I have a quick question about what
you just said do you work with a Postal
Inspector to follow up on these crimes
oh we do
and it sounds like it's like a flashback
to the 60s acid soaking paper and is
that what's going on there when we when
we change practice to divert something
somebody always finds some other way to
do it yeah there's always a new mouse
trap isn't there okay
representative Newman
thank you I just have a quick question
about the northern correctional facility
and the and the Gen the regional Men's
prison do you have the same
responsibility and are they similar in
for men as well and the policies
implemented by the Department of
Corrections are consistent across all
Sites with one minor exception we may do
something that is
gender-centric for women and or men that
would be the only deviation and the
northern correctional facility for men
does not have a robust special housing
unit that is our most restrictive
housing unit it has a few cells that we
would use as a transitional location
before we would send somebody down to
the Men's prison if they engaged in
conduct that would result in that
follow-up yeah and just as far as your
staff you go I know he talked about the
minimum wage
is there a retirement system is it the
state retirement system
um how does that work
so that's a great question so the
changes in retirement some people will
say
switch from 20 years to 25 years we lost
some people I think we saw that
statistically the new group of
individuals coming in we'll say to you
I have to work 80 hours a week at base
pay to get to equalized pay of my other
law enforcement partner who's doing and
has meets the same minimum certification
requirements and why is that the case so
we have to get equalized pay for
equalized certification but we literally
literally need more people to come and
be interested in being Corrections
Officers and it's a defined benefit
pension is that correct to find benefit
to get a they get a payment based upon
the years of service yeah just the same
retirement system laws that are on the
books today depending on your date of
hire
I think that's people have to understand
I myself have a pension and the pension
is is uh
a very big driver when people get to the
point where they get into retirement
because it's really really a big thing
it is and the changes uh from last
legislative cycle if I recall correctly
that adjusted how that calculation
happened was to the benefit of the staff
that work in the Department of
Corrections those were positive changes
I will tell you when and I'm not trying
to tell you what to do certainly but
never do that when the retirement laws
are opened in in bills it scares all of
my staff so I have to work on what they
say what is the legislature trying to do
and I said we're going to have to wait
and find out
and and we do too
there we go
thank you commissioner for coming today
you know I reckon back to my years in
college when I studied criminal justice
with with a few of your correct your pro
probation and parole officers that were
my instructors
um I remember early uh during the
pandemic there was
um National Guardsmen that were called
to assist your department uh if you
could just comment on the services they
provided if they're still there
um and if you have a current need for
them as well thank you for that question
uh covid-19 are the toughest two uh
years of my career for the reasons that
makes sense and covid-19 not only
affected everyone's life and and people
got to work from home my staff did not
get to work from home uh they had to
continue to come to work but with that
said Copa 19 affected their families so
did we have people that themselves as
employees were affected by covid-19
infection yes but then their families
were affected by the illness so when we
started to look at the numbers of people
who were literally out of the office
either for their own illness or
supporting their families it did trigger
my ass to the governor to bring in
members of the National Guard to
supplement our security forces
we use them differently in New Hampshire
than they were used in other states
other states put National Guard service
members all over the place in different
posts we made a purposeful decision
through collaboration with the Attorney
General's office myself the National
Guard and the governor's office to put
them in posts that did not put them in
the direct supervision of people
incarcerated because that is a unique
expertise and then also working with
director skippa over at police stands
and training Council to put them through
a course of curricula that would help
Orient and Orient them to those roles so
to your answer we put them in non-direct
positions within the organization
perimeter security control rooms things
of that nature and we would not have
made it through those times without the
National Guard support so we've used
them twice and we don't have any
National Guard service members in the
organization right now but I am
constantly monitoring what is going on
and if I have to make that ask and those
individuals that were assigned to us
came from the National Guard card with
military policing experience and we're
picked specifically for their career
backgrounds
and as a follow-up to that were you able
to recruit any of those National Guards
members for your staff
I know that the military police are
actually on the Texas border so yeah um
I tried
I tried and we are a veterans friendly
veterans friendly employer so we are
connected in that way
but I'll try to recruit anybody I have
no shame
thank you commissioner um that's going
to have to be it we're way behind tell
I I would just again thank you for that
that was literally just a snapshot from
September to November if I gave you the
whole list of the places we've been for
the last probably two years it would it
would cover the whole the whole slide
deck we have been down to those areas
um pursuant to that question and I know
we're all out of time if there are
opportunities that you think we might
not be aware of please let us know we'll
send somebody absolutely thank you
okay again thank you so much I encourage
everyone to um get the commissioner's
contact information they're very
responsive over there getting back to
you uh we will see here again I'm sure
this and um I would reach out to you
regarding the potential for visits
um as the session goes on thank you
you and next with my extreme apologies I
will call the representative from the
it appears uh you got off the hook oh
what was it I didn't even see it go
ahead
I know thank you for taking my question
um last year
um I know they talked a little about
um driving basically white while high
okay
um can you tell us a little bit about
um how you determine that or make that
and uh you know an officer will be
looking for
signs have been carrying that that
interaction that he has with the driver
if you know the typical uh over the
years you know the uh
impaired drivers into the alcohol use
um you know there will be different
things that the doctors are looking for
um that they can testify to that they've
observed and observations that are made
um drugs you know different drugs
there's a lot of the same uh impairment
that shows now that there may be some
more specific things
experts throughout the state uh state
employees as well as local departments
he asked to come in and do an evaluation
with the whole program uh for the GRE
program uh training that they received
and
approach
is that does that answer your question
somewhat follow-up okay so if you think
someone is impaired
okay on a stop
do you call someone out to that location
or that's a situation where you're gonna
we will arrest
evidence
now there are Opportunities For The
Individual to continue their cooperation
through you know breath tests
um the evaluation for the drug
recognition
things uh things to that effect just as
the officer is testing building their
case some sometimes these interactions
are a result of a quarter vehicle act
there may be the increase involved and
thank you
um just one quick question it's a
follow-up on on what what she was
speaking about my so what you're saying
is um I'm wondering if I missed
something in this so of course there
would be the um
um I forget what she said it was but the
um
an officer who is trained to identify
right but somewhere in between the uh
the initial encounter in that assessment
that's you know on the street assessment
and going to court for something
um are you saying that the evidence
presented would be the person's
assessment the expert's assessment or I
mean wouldn't there be a test in the
meantime to
yeah so we were talking about the
they are you know applying the laws that
they should have been born before that
interaction there's opportunities for
like I said breath test uh you know
potentially uh what does
um and potentially a recognition of
effort that I've given there
they're out making their observations
and giving the tests that they give and
then all that information together and
about to
later that if there goes to that level
okay
yeah it does I just I didn't hear
anything about the test I'm going that
seems like it would be important thank
you and I'm I'm really pleased to see
the members um engaging and asking all
these questions I'm going to try and
arrange for um the opportunity for
ride-alongs with everyone
um with either State Police or local
police is still in the planning stages
so you'll be able to see what it looks
like firsthand and I hope you all Avail
yourselves of that once we get it set up
um one more question go ahead
representative Reed so um when somebody
stopped for DUI you have the
breathalyzer test there's no test yet
for other substance other substances
like marijuana you don't have a
breathalyzer or on the spot test for
thank you very much for your time and
and last but most definitely not least
the executive director Sarah rothbone
Anna of the New Hampshire Public
Defenders
thank you uh the you said that the in
the upcoming budget you had requested a
certain amount
what will that set your hourly rate at
um
um you can see we we can't escape even
begin to match those things but those
are the rates just about fast and I want
going from 60 to 90 dollars he is
competitive it just may not be conducted
In This Moment In This housing market in
the labor market and then this public
service marketing but it is the race and
they've finally moved
um we have a contract returning program
it's basic adjustments they're not quite
yeah I was just curious to see if the
what you submitted for the for your
budget request if if it would get you
where you would like to be or at least
and no one was going to raise space and
and it was a discussion about that okay
yeah thinking about what that is
somebody
vamp
questions from the committee
representative scitec
do you mind sticking around for a minute
I have some questions that I don't want
to tie up the committee and in the words
of one of your clients you're pretty
um
you know
representative chairman oh you want to
follow up good
as a point of information uh High School
uh Salem High School is paying its Latin
representative
response
it's a question
I recall from my four years
on the committee that's on the other
side of that on that other room over
there
that what we're talking about here is a
an individual's constitutional right to
representation
and to put a cost on that is pretty
difficult
but I my recollection is there is
if the person is able to to afford it a
requirement for them to pay for those
services and that is actually collected
by probation and parole is that correct
yeah
probation
right
right and and it never ever will
actually meet what you have spent in
their defense
now
um
I agree
representative sailing
thank you so much
um you spoke a bit about some of the
challenges for public defenders I'm
wondering if there's funding for and
support for mental health services to
ensure their ability to continue doing
thank you
um I first of all thank you I I
appreciate what you do so much I wanted
to ask
uh I have had experiences with uh trying
to assist people with who who have a
public defender in other states and um
it's been
not a good experience
um you keep talking about uh the idea of
you want to have the quality of
representation I appreciate that so much
and I believe that you do and I'm
curious uh what you might think I guess
this is more of a subjective question
but what do you think is kind of the
difference and and why that happens is
it uh you know how is it that you are
able to provide this quality of care
service and you know I know the
priorities and things like that I think
that that's that's wonderful I'm just
representative Newman
thank you uh I'm just trying do you have
any comments on what I'm trying to
figure out is is who can apply for this
um what kind of financial stuff do they
take into consideration and once you've
made the decision that someone is either
qualified or not qualified is the
qualified individual then on their own
and they just go find out find
representation in the private Community
foreign
uh
thank you very much it has been very
enlightening and I'm thank you for um
responding to my invitation and um if
you have any information you'd like to
hand out or pass on or anything
throughout the year if you're feeling
thank you very much
oh
um so I just want to briefly address the
committee because I didn't have a chance
to before we started
um as we noticed today it was very
informal and we all got to ask our
questions and that's the way I like to
conduct hearings if we can all
do that civilly I could plan on
continuing that way for the rest of the
year
just everyone if you have a follow-up
question make sure you say follow up
please I noticed someone I'm not going
to mention anyone stuck like seven
questions and one of their questions but
I would like to be able to continue the
way we did it this was really good it
was really informative so let's um if we
can all if we can all play nice together
that's the way we're going to continue
and if any of you have any questions for
me I'm happy to take them there will be
a schedule coming out shortly
um we will be having three meetings next
week on Wednesday Thursday and Friday we
have a lot of bills it's looking like
we're going to be somewhere around
between 85 and 90.
um and I don't want to be here in June I
don't know about you so we're going to
crank through these as best we can and
we'll get our work done
representative Bolden you had a question
actually a request
um between the seven questions and a
question and then not saying follow-up I
was wondering if maybe just off the top
of your head if you could because we
have so many new people on the committee
who are first timers I mean if you could
run through your expectations for how to
conduct yourself in Committee in general
I think it might be helpful sure
um I I would expect everyone to just
make sure you if you want to ask a
question raise your hand wait wait till
you're recognized if you have a
follow-up just go ahead and put your
hand up I will universally almost 100 of
the time allow the follow-up question
um when we have witnesses testifying I
expect the questions to be pertinent and
Germaine something that you really want
to know the answer to that you will help
think will help the rest of the
committee make a decision I don't want
to see gotcha questions
um there's generally a rule regarding
electronic items during hearings I'm not
going to be really ridiculous about that
either but if I see people Googling
stuff on a laptop or a phone to give
gotcha questions to the witness then I'm
going to have to enforce that if you
need it just to look at text to see if
someone's texting you or kid are you
going to take a phone call I'm going to
be flexible about that as long as we can
all
get our business done then that's good
um
let me see what else
what about the wood
oh yeah yeah
um what would we call the Wichita leaves
um yeah that's don't ask questions that
you already know the answer to just so
that the rest of us can hear what you
already know that would be would you
believe that I already know this answer
to this question but I'm going to ask it
anyway please don't do those
let me see what else uh representative
Newman go ahead yeah I just have a
question about I mean I've been thinking
about electronic equipment and using how
you use it or abuse it
but you can use your phone to uh to get
the text of of uh bills that come up
that you don't have a paper copy for and
oh sure yeah stuff like that but it's
much easier to observe on a computer so
I don't know if computers are ramboten
or what because that's computers are a
bit much if we're all sitting behind
laptops it's just kind of disrespectful
to the witness
um it just doesn't it's not a good look
for all of us if you have a tablet
tablet put that in your lap but having a
computer screen yeah I mean I just think
it's much easier to do that and if a
tablet is is being used yeah in any
conspicuous manner yes to get
information because you might go back
and be looking at something that you've
written up for this already or whatever
sure it's important that we treat each
other with respect and I I'd like to
forget about parties when we're in here
I really really would um this is about
criminal justice
um so I'm going to try my best to do
that and if we all do that together
it'll be really cool
um but above respect for each other I
want to make sure that we show respect
for the witnesses regardless if they say
the most ridiculous thing you've ever
heard
you smile and you let them say their
piece they came here to talk to you they
some of them traveled a long long way to
get here
and we have the respect to listen to
them and that's fine and move to the
next subject
um and and that's how above all that's
one of the things that's going to make
me use this ridiculous Hammer is um
talking to disrespectfully to a witness
I just wanted to ask about your first
two words you said you want to forget
about yeah before you started I did not
hear what you said party affiliation
party we're a team in here we're our own
party I think I got party but I didn't
know what you I didn't know whether you
were talking about just the best party
or yeah well that's at the end of the
year but while we're in here I'd like to
be the criminal justice party so if and
I know that's not reasonable to every
extent but the best we can
um representative Bolden
um while we were here today we got two
notices for upcoming
oh okay so 18th and 19th and so I was
wondering if you have a sense of
um how frequently each week will be
meeting and what days
um generally it's going to be
um it's going to be Wednesday Thursday
or Friday
um right now I want it we have as you
know we have those first bills that have
the financial implications we have to
take care of first so we may have
um three days a week just to get those
out of the way I'd like to be able to go
back to two
um yeah three days a week so Wednesday
Thursday Friday weekly for the for at
least a few weeks yeah yeah and then and
then I'd like to go back if I can to
just Wednesday Thursdays nobody wants to
be here on Friday but we got to do we're
going to do because we share this room
with ways and means
and is it I'm sorry follow-up no go
ahead um is it your expectation that on
the vacation weeks that we'll still be
having hearings I don't want to if we
can that's why you're going to see a
heavy schedule coming up um I don't want
to because I know people want to spend
time with their kids and their grandkids
and I I don't want to be here either but
we have to do what we have to do so if
we put in the time now maybe we can
avoid the vacation weeks
last one Amanda last one anything else I
wonder about I'll just just email myself
um so on weeks when there's session and
it's like on a Thursday and it's one day
are we meeting do you think the
Wednesday before or just not at all in
those weeks no I would think the
Wednesday before I don't think we have
the luxury of taking off a whole week um
if we want the vacation weeks off so
yep
um oh representative Murray
sure the one thing I will ask
um I I really would appreciate if no
one's live tweeting our meetings you
know you can tweet later you can bash
Republicans all you want a bash Democrat
don't bash our committee and don't bash
each other especially when we're trying
to work together so live tweeting I wish
you wouldn't
um but checking emails whatever you got
foreign
just today was super informal it will be
a little bit more informal when we're
having a public hearing
um a little more formal when we're
having actual public hearings
um but as I said I'm going to try to
keep it as relaxed as possible because
and also one other thing I want to
mention I'm going to try and arrange as
many field trips as possible and as many
guest speakers as possible I think
informed legislators are better
legislators and a lot of times hearing
about something reading about something
or even seeing something in old episodes
of Law and Order are not quite as good
as going to court and sitting there and
watching defendants be brought up and
put in the dock and and have an attorney
represent them and what's going what's
all involved in that or ride along or
visit to the to the prison they'll be
strictly obviously voluntary I'm not
going to insist anyone go but I will try
and make the opportunity there for you
all
representative Murray
are we uh if you have to use the
restroom by all means um please do um
just try to be if there's a witness
testifying just try to keep yourself as
inconspicuous as possible so as not to
distract from them uh representative uh
salic
um I just wanted to support your idea
about going for a ride-along um I did
that last year with their two years ago
with the Laconia police department and
went with two separate officers and I
would encourage people if you schedule a
ride along with the Department to
um first of all not necessarily do it in
your town because it's really
embarrassing when you pull over your
friends
um but
um but also to seek out the opportunity
to go with more than one person
um the two officers that happened to
take me had very very dramatically
different views of fleecing where one
viewed as an opportunity for connections
and the other was eager to find as many
people as he could decide during the
time we were together I will be trying
to arrange it through the state police
and potentially Concord or Manchester I
don't think um
coming out to the you call it community
of Deerfield where I live is going to
really give you an idea or flavor of
what's going on in police in New
Hampshire so um I'll I'll try and make
that available to everyone and and as
the weeks go by we'll figure that out
but thank you I appreciate that
representative Newman I just have a
suggestion maybe you could have more
microphones at the uh that's definitely
yeah and then
make sure that they're on when when the
testimony is given because I haven't got
my hearing aids yet but I need them okay
and those thingies over there are
actually kind of annoying I gotta figure
out that I can't see the witnesses I
think they're speakers I don't know why
they have to be like up at face level
okay um that's it if you have any more
questions
um email me whenever you want
um please give your contact information
to um your Majority Leader
um so that I can get in touch with you
if there's any last minute changes
storms what have you um and that'll be